I want to let you know that we have
added shows for Saturday November 5th in
San Diego
uh the first two sold out so we now have
so Saturday November 5th we are also
adding a Sunday November 6th show for
San Diego and those tickets will be on
sale Wednesday
uh September 14th at 10 A.M Pacific
Standard time
theovan.com
t-o-u-r I'm also excited to announce
we've got brand new merch up on the Theo
Von store check out rat king racing
collections
shirts hoodies hats and multiple designs
um if you like racing if you like
threatening your Uber driver and making
them go faster and if you like just damn
just burning gasoline baby then you'll
love uh Rat King Racing collection get
that hitter baby
he's on his birdie boy relapse tour for
the rest of this year he just wrapped up
his fully loaded tour this summer and um
and you can see new episodes of his
something's burning cooking show on
YouTube I'm grateful to have him here
today one of the hardest working men in
comedy Mr Burt pressure
[Music]
sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
so like it's like I don't know the
benefit you know like like Timberland
what's he used right maybe maybe the
best podcaster we have of our general
you and Tim Dylan are probably the two
best podcasters I know that I enjoy
watching I love Rogan Rogan's obviously
the king I love
I love watching Rogan but and I love but
I love watching you and Tim the way you
guys think now price point wise right
say there's let's talk about uh these
companies that come in they go we're
doing it right we spent
fifty thousand dollars on cameras we
spent a hundred thousand dollars on
microphones we got state of the art
board yeah and then you go what about
just a laptop
do you have one of those yeah so right
right but but I do think that if you I
do think here's what I learned from
Rogan if you invest a little more money
in it you care more
and if you care more you get a better
product
I think that that's probably true and I
think guests come and they see that you
care more yeah it feels more eloquent
yeah
um
yeah it's one of the reasons like
sometimes it's like I would like to get
into like a nicer Studio space like our
studio is great very good but it's like
but then also you don't want to go too
corporate of a studio where it feels
like where it doesn't feel like Rogue
you know like yeah and you also don't
want to do it out of your house which
I've been doing for the past [ __ ]
eight years and so people are like do
you live here yeah okay is that your
daughter can I meet her and you're like
Georgia grab a towel yeah uh she's doing
this audio for us right now but as soon
as like I want to get bigger guys you
know who I want to get I'm being dead
serious we talked about this a little
bit and I think you're the only person
who'll get this but let me guess who it
is oh if you guess it if you guessed it
I'll spend the rest of the show with my
flip-flop in my mouth oh dude that's
gonna mess up the chat
but I'll try let me see it's uh can I
ask for a clue or not yes okay
is it a black
person no
there are a couple that I'd like to get
on I'd like to get on uh I like Killer
Mike on I like Killer Mike I like Snoop
on
um I Like Big Boy from Outcast I'd Like
T.I I should give a shout out to TI
about his car keep saying stuff you're
just eliminating guests I was gonna
guess
oh yeah that's right so you're going
with the you going with the white dude
oh I'm going with a white dude I think
he's white I don't even know his name to
be honest with you it's hot in here guys
can y'all cut that AC on
um I drank a lot yesterday and I woke up
in the middle of the night in a [ __ ]
Sizzle I mean I was so hot and all of a
sudden my body went
and [ __ ] poured sweat back to sleep
yeah yeah like almost like when a truck
stops and it's like
it woke me up I was so hot my [ __ ]
wife Liam was was like you gotta keep
you got a cape hey boss this is how Leon
talks
I was doing I'm doing this impressively
Anna She [ __ ] hates it and I got off
stage in Atlantic City this weekend and
uh and Dave Williamson's like I think
you're doing Theo
as Leanne he's like yeah Leanne never
says gang gang when she sucks your dick
gang gang son
[Music]
um but uh yeah but I don't even know
about that coach I drop it on the bottom
of the smoking drinking by a Diet Coke I
ain't drinking that go that's all he
only Diet Coke right now
um [ __ ] oh my God there's a lot of black
people I'd like to have on my podcast oh
you gotta get some you gotta I don't
have enough black people on my podcast
none of us nobody does nobody does
Donnell's the only I know Darnell's
money too
money but every oh God every time you
think you're like man I gotta diversify
a little you're like hey Darnell
everybody in podcasting is like that
dude
Williams would be good oh Chris Rock
Dave Chappelle I don't count them as
like in like the group because they're
just Comics I want to reach out you know
I'd like Cornell West Cornell West let's
bring him up he's a singer no
no he's not he's not oh there he is huh
Dr Cornell West oh damn huh he's badass
dude
yeah is he really like a real uh
prolific thinker and stuff yeah yeah
yeah he's the reason I'm gonna say this
there's no proof to what I'm about to
say he's the reason Chris Rock's special
was so good bring the pain Chris Rock
started hanging around dudes like this
on Sunday they do like Sunday supper
where they talk about politics and talk
about the world and talk about things
and he just hang out by the way I'm not
certain what I'm saying is accurate at
all I might have just dreamed this yeah
and so I had a dream about David Spade
last night you did yeah and I should
call him and let him know I was thinking
about him but so he uh he yeah what
happened I want to know about this guy
looks really interesting he's really
interesting uh he's like just a thinker
I think he works at Harvard and he just
is he's always on Bill Maher and I just
love him on Bill Murray he's always got
a good take you know some people are
aligned just straight politics and that
bores me I like a person that'll float
and go like well those kids were wrong
yeah yeah yeah yeah I like something
it's got some uh that's got some Nuance
to their own ideas yeah I don't I don't
to their views I don't have any of that
you don't no pretty basic views well
do you and I flip-flop a lot I'm gonna
flip-flop a lot I'm gonna try this one
but that's okay man I don't think that's
bad or is there alcohol in this no okay
um okay people on one of my pockets well
let's get into it okay
um I uh so if it's a I'm gonna say Bill
Clinton it's not
although he would be good he would be
good but he would be good if like off
camera you know yes he's like well that
was really good Bart are these things
still rolling and I go no and he goes
man I [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] when I was
President my favorite thing to do come
in them just come in them and go yeah
take that oh yeah that's presidential
seed baby and spit in their mouths and
just throw a towel at them go clean
yourself up or yeah
and get back on the bench babe no
Razorback hey what did you like was it
like starting for the first time
Razorbacks
dude when you think about the fact that
he went to that he's out of the
University of Arkansas him and Hillary
straight up met at the University of
Arkansas dude yeah was it was she ever
could pull up young pictures of Hillary
was she ever like like really hot you
could see that up oh hold on yeah you
can see it or like
let's look at let's take some looks at
her
because you got to be like Jackie
Onassis hot Jackie Kennedy hot
I mean you got look at
[Music]
um
wow I mean bill was not planning on
doing well I think Bill is looking for
someone to help him with his homework
he looks like a starting center for the
Nets in 1972.
hi boy hi it's Bill Clinton is that
that's a good impression right that's
pretty good hey you ever think Bill
Clinton said the n-word
let me think about it hold on
I bet it's been a while you've been
thinking it's been a while yeah oh come
on you think he says it recently I think
he's one of those guys that just still
drops it every now and then just to
Hillary just a Hillary
just the best yeah who's calling you
he's like it's Obama hi oh boy hey
what's up is that I lost it I had the
accent for a second let me think that is
Bill Clinton uh that sounds like you're
getting a little fuzzy a little fuzzy
rare there yeah I get really fuzzy yeah
I'm not I'm not right now oh
Jim I used to think Jimmy Kimmel looked
like Fozzy the bear let me think like
early General Kimmel when he was like a
little more oh yeah I could see that
bring up Fozzy can we get a look at an
idea what Fozzie looks like
um
no hold on hey oh that's Fozzie who am I
thinking of hey no that's not that old
uh driving along it takes the fun out of
my way and think they're at a highways
what is somebody saying that right I
think it's we picked up a weirdo Life is
a Highway
I'm gonna run it all night long have you
ever done anything as good as that think
about that right artistically
do you think you've put out one thing
that it equals that song I think of that
all the [ __ ] time when you think of
one hit wonders like rat Right Round and
Round
Your Love Will Come Away just give it
time time round yeah do you think you've
done anything as good as that once like
like put out one piece of work where you
go that was that was I take it you you
have
I think there's some there's some beats
that I've put out there that are pretty
good I think I think my cousin got bit
by a gay is as good as round and round
that made me laugh so [ __ ] hard yeah
it's a true story man it's sad too yeah
yeah
but it's like that's what the city's
gone into man it's [ __ ] Obama's
aquarium out here I mean it's it's
[ __ ] Biden's aquarium out here dude
it's aquarium out on the streets here
bro it's insane everybody's biting I
just heard about this Hunter Biden guy
yeah he uh does he does uh crack he used
to do it they said I don't know if he's
better oh so it's not recent no oh well
then whatever I don't think everyone can
grow oh then yeah whatever I thought he
was doing it like today he was on mayor
he was on Marin's podcast I didn't hear
it though he was on Marilyn's podcast
with the Neil Marin's podcast I think
Zach
I think you're thinking of he was on
getting Doug with high oh he was
dude I'm just gullible today man
um I feel like we haven't even started
this conversation when we started the
show yeah okay okay
he was on Marc Maron wow and Mark Maron
you know Mark Maron he'll hold you to
the fire did he did he say so tell me
about the crack in the bathtub in the
listen to it did he
Marin's been doing he's got like a beef
I guess or something with Rogan and Shob
huh uh or like some of his material and
stuff has been about
um I know he has a beef with Rogan he's
been about it I'd added a few things out
on podcasts you did yeah I was like oh
[ __ ] him I don't want to be the I'm
going to be the [ __ ] the fire starter
between this thing yeah you can [ __ ]
say that out loud I was like
we can edit this out it was just nope
it's been uh don't
I live a life where I try not to I
there's there's [ __ ] I've said on
podcast that I completely regret yeah
but it's out there so and so if I start
editing now then I look like I've gotten
so much better I go I got to keep it
consistent yeah yeah I got to be kind of
ignorant keep going
um what do you uh only think about what
that guest is
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you a huge hint
and I just don't think is it that singer
oh I would love to have pink
I would love to have pink
I would love to have pink and not tell
my wife and daughters and have them walk
in and they would
[ __ ] lose their [ __ ] I'll tell you
what I'll even tell go this far pink and
bring her boyfriend and I'll get a
tattoo right there yeah cause her
boyfriend does the two work oh he does
heart heart heart heart foundation or
something heart and weight heart I like
Kat Von D boy I like Kat Von D too she's
in recovery I think her tattoos are much
better now why yeah I heard there was a
period of time where they're a little
sloppy she was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna hit the
cocktail and she was like I added to it
she was hot and she still is hot as [ __ ]
oh yeah she looks good man bring her
picture up bring up a picture of it she
is really sexy yep
yeah she looks nice dude
um was there a fur before you loved your
wife was there a first love for you did
you ever have like yeah yeah wow
Jennifer Stevens eighth grade oh eighth
grade she really dialed in what I liked
in women she had great feast she still
has great feet I'm sure great feet feet
yeah she used to sit in Mr yarnell's
class with her foot like this and she
just dangled her oh she dangled her shoe
and I seventh grade eighth grade
it's the first time I realized I was
straight where I was like like whatever
a gay kid goes I think that's why I'm
empathetic towards like anyone who's
struggling with their sexuality I've I
don't think maybe I haven't always been
like this but I think definitely when I
realized that at that moment I was out
of control I was I was I wanted I wanted
uh tan blonde women for the rest of my
life with great feet great feet were had
to be a thing
I was out of control I couldn't control
my thoughts I never listened to Mr
yarnell's class all I really learned is
about barnstorming it seemed to be the
only thing more interesting than
Jennifer Stevens feet and uh
and then dangle that sandal oh God and I
remember being like Oh I'm [ __ ]
um bit by the bug oh and so if that if
you feel that way about boys and you're
a boy you know like at the same age
eighth grade and you're like
God damn it man but it must be crazy at
that age because all boys are suddenly
being like I've been jerking off all
night and you're just sitting there as a
gay boy you're like it would all be so
hard especially like we used to do a lot
of gay [ __ ] growing up like if you got
in the shower and you weren't and you
were like a little white we'd start
slapping you and then we just put
handprints all over you imagine being an
albino gay kid trying to figure yourself
out and you get in there and everyone's
like slapping you're like oh
hey if you opened those cigars you're
like I'm bad I'm bad those cigars are
really great cigars they are yeah
they're tatuates
this is an interesting point because
like when did you find out you were
straight
let me thank God the meaning it was in
you you went what the [ __ ] was that you
know like not just going like uh you
know watching Wonder Woman and being
like she looks pretty or whatever but
like you're like I'm in love with this
girl I need I want this girl in my life
and I got her I got Jennifer Stevens I
dated her for like probably six months
wow she broke up with me to date
Thompson rankins
um that's the whitest name you'll ever
it was the worst he was the coolest dude
yeah he was he was the first guy that
taught me that was okay to shower like
with other dudes yeah him Truett Gardner
him into a gardener okay that's enough
dudes in the shower okay
even in the story I feel like we don't
need
you're just like you told me Ron was
there Alan they told me I needed to name
my dick really yeah they told me they
like I I was really uncomfortable I was
in like probably eighth grade they were
in ninth grade and we were playing
football JV football and uh we all had
to get in the shower afterwards and I
was really uncomfortable and then and by
the way I'm sorry they're two grown men
in their 50s with children and just
sharing the story yeah and they're like
hey man if you're uncomfortable this is
so [ __ ] bizarre they're like if
you're uncomfortable
there's a process yeah showering your
boxers I said for real and they go we
don't care if you're not comfortable
with your body showering your boxers I
was like I can shower my boxers and go
hey it's just us we don't give a [ __ ] so
I shout out to my boxers and then the
next day after football practice I came
into my boxers
and they were like uh they're like you
know one day you're gonna have to you
know just let you know like there's
gonna be other guys in here it's gonna
be weird you're in your boxers it's okay
with us but like one of the things you
can do to help you feel a little more
confident name your dick I said for real
I said yeah I named my dick John Henry
that day oh yeah yeah I need my dick
John Henry and and I got very
comfortable showering I got very
comfortable showering and then I went to
an all boys Catholic High School and I
got uncomfortable again really oh they
had Hogs they had like legit Hogs really
dude and they had because I was
showering in JV football so the oldest
kid was ninth grade right I go to in the
ninth grade and now I'm showering with
like seniors and they were men they were
grown men with [ __ ] yeah and I had a
penis like I I saw the penis they had
[ __ ] wow and I remember remember broken
your heart
uh Panic it was more Panic yeah Panic it
was like panic I was the same size as
Thompson and Drew we were all like
roughly just boys you know and then you
go in and you see like hairy [ __ ] and
they this is I don't remember this about
the showers I just had the the one
Sprout like the one mushroom with all
the spigots on it and you'd and so
everyone was showering around to one
pole and so it was like eight dudes
around one pole showering so everyone's
looking at each other's dicks almost
like an octopus that's insane they did
that and the only thing to block you
from seeing the person's dick was that
pole that one pole but then you're
looking at Dicks all over here and then
dudes would piss on you and you're like
oh [ __ ] what am I how much I think I'm
getting sexually assaulted oh man yeah I
remember that very distinctly dude I oh
man I was so scared to go anywhere where
they had
um where everybody had to be like naked
and stuff you know I was like I think it
was very good look at it that's it yeah
were you really yeah I think so man it
was also like really
I remember like
what are we talking about the first
penis we ever saw first penises I ever
saw first penis I ever saw where I went
okay that's bigger than mine wow was
Jeff Hartley wow and I remember did you
tell him uh no but he knew he knew oh he
knows to this day and by the way he's
he's the only one watching this going
that's right
he's gonna clip this out and send it
around to our friends so he'll be like
hey
um we had uh oh I remember I've told
this story before but we had a fella
somebody got a hot tub in our town right
yeah and we'd never I mean no one even
could imagine it right yeah so we go
over there at somebody's birthday party
this fell a little William
and it was his birthday and some guy who
got invited there was older than us
so we're all in the hot tub just being
children I mean we were young you know
probably 10 or 11. yeah and this other
fella uh this other fella CJ was his
name anyway he's under the water and
he'd been pleasuring himself and we
didn't know so he stands up and just
starts like spewing out into the
thing oh that's so unfair and bro we'd
never seen it we didn't know what was
happening right yeah and little William
grab thought something was had like his
but like he was leaking out of his body
he was just gonna
keep he applied first aid he was like I
said eternity
before he put two he put two hands on me
this kid was big dude this kid had
probably won a title belt doing
something and he was just he put two
hands on it and the big guy punched him
in the neck bro and I always felt so bad
for that kid like just how do you all
those first moments at once you see the
ejaculate and then you try to help and
then you get [ __ ] and now it's in the
water so it's coming up on your do you
remember when you jerk off in the tub
and then you didn't realize that the [ __ ]
would just get on your chest hairs yeah
and it would like press it this way so
it looked like you'd put gel in your
stomach do you remember time like when
you first started jerking off what was
your move because like mine was mine was
to like rub it like this oh against your
stomach yeah like put it on my back and
then rub it like this and then wow
almost like a clitoris kinda yeah kinda
yeah exactly wow and then and then I
realized
I realized like I remember watching
movies and they were like hey and then
like one day I kind of put pen to paper
getting all Italian but they go like
they go out you know he's in there
jerking off and I was like yeah I guess
his movie jerking off I didn't know
and then one day I went I did it and I
went oh that makes sense that's why
they're doing this because they do it to
their dicks and it's so much more
efficient and I was like no that's
that's all I'm gonna do it for now on
suddenly you're just walking around town
just playing songs guys I'm alive I'm
alive I used to think jerking off was
gay wow and I kind of came to terms with
being gay because I was like I can't
quit yeah I was like I guess I'm gay I
guess if this is gay I'm gay as [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] the gayest dude in town because
I'm jerking off at least once a day oh
damn bro damn that's insane man yeah
that's when there were rumors about gays
oh so you didn't know you were like I
guess I'm getting AIDS yeah like because
I didn't ages on 2020 and they didn't
tell you how you got AIDS they told you
they just told you gay guys were getting
it and I'm jerking off like [ __ ]
three times a day going [ __ ] I'm getting
AIDS I remember going down to my dad and
going do you think this is AIDS wow and
he was like huh I was this close to
going I'm jerking off a lot okay I'm gay
just on 2020. they said us that we're
getting AIDS and so do you think I have
AIDS I remember thinking because they
were it was uh it was uh carcinoma In
Their Skin it was like skin cancer oh
yeah smokers little yeah smokers
freckles they used to call them yeah and
so uh my dad's like you don't have AIDS
I was like are you sure and he's like
I'm 100 certain you don't have AIDS wow
he's like is there something I need to
know about you and I was like
I never mind wow I almost told him I
jerked off twice oh the first time it
ever happened first time it ever
happened
I was uh I'll save the names for where I
was but I was in a pool and there was a
hose with a gun on it and I I don't know
I just shot my dick and then all of a
sudden it was just you shot the hose at
your wiener underwater underwater yeah
it feels that's a good that's a good
thing by the way I did that I did that
when I was like 45 randomly I was in a
pool and I was like and I had a hose and
I just I just randomly just sprayed my
balls see if it felt good 45. dude
holds up still cool
[Laughter]
just disclose the jerking off in my butt
in your own pool I was like oh come on
man I can't do that to my family my
[ __ ] wife comes out of the pool her
hair is over to the side like something
about Mary I'm like sorry no but uh I
remember jerking off in that pool or
like jerking off and masturbating with
the hose in the pool yeah I'm gonna go
pick up someone at the airport and I
almost and I had my first orgasm
I'd had white dreams as a kid I didn't
know what they were but I had wet dreams
and and I knew they were like the best
dreams I was always riding horses in
those dreams and so I almost said to my
dad I had the craziest thing happened to
me today dude every so what you're
saying though the the uh I'm sorry I'm
stuck on that horse thing please
and you just what I would be riding
horses
and and then I'd have a wet dream I'd
have an orgasm like first grade through
third grade okay so I'd have wet dreams
and it was always me riding horses and
then Theo I rode a horse at full Sprint
was there anything in your butt you feel
like I was just okay it was like a
vibration like a
[Music]
um
and then I'd be riding a horse riding a
horse and then I just I just have a wet
dream not wet dream it was just a it was
a nocturnal Mission but it wasn't like
like it was just an orgasm while you
sleep but what is it like is it like I'm
gonna tell me like well
it's funny because I really it was just
me on a horse just riding a horse okay
and then
and then all of a sudden I'd be riding
the horse and I would my dick would be
hard I was a kid and I'd just be like
huh well and then boom it would hit and
I would wake up oh yeah that was [ __ ]
I need to get a horse yeah I need to get
a horse ASAP Richard yeah your black
stallion came out where the kid was
riding on the beach I was like luckiest
kid in the [ __ ] world I can't just
ski just blowing loads all over a horse
you know losing your hair it's it's
alarming to a man
because you've had your hair your whole
life
and people don't turn it in there's not
a lost and found for your hair where you
can go over there and rummage through
the strands and through the dirty
barrettes and get your hairs back
they just drift Into The Ether
well
you need to take care of your hair and
there are only two FDA approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps offers both of them
keeps has a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality no more
dreaming about hair
no more fantasizing about Sideburn
remember prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months to see
results so act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to get your
first month free
keeps.com slash Theo
you know sometimes people are smacking
their gum and you say hey hey Eddie
hey Belinda quit smacking your gum
well sometimes people might be smacking
on a blue chew
and at that way they're smacking their
way
up to a strong meet
up to decent body
up to you know prominent Wiener that's
what they do Bluetooth
if you don't like swallowing pills no
problems here
Bluetooth licensed medical providers
we'll work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
they're chewable
they are the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis
it's an online prescription service no
visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations
yep that's true and here's a special
deal for you
to get that good meat
try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code Theo at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code t-h-e-o
to receive your first month free
take care
of your body get that wiener Stout baby
and then and then I rode a horse as an
adult I rode a horse for Travel Channel
at full Sprint I wonder if I remember
this or not
um I was we were in Texas we were
running uh buff uh Buffalo through Texas
and they brought me out and they've got
me and I got real comfortable on a horse
and then the guy John I forget his last
name John was the he ran the
I mean nothing that you can't be
stunning gay but like you can be a stun
gay now there's very there's like really
I think gangster [ __ ] gay dudes you
know I mean
nowadays you can't like I think kids are
growing up with such fluidity that I
don't think they see gay the way we saw
one of their kids yeah they just are
like no you fall in love with the person
um but but he this guy John said why
don't you take her and let her go loose
and and I never really ridden a horse at
full Sprint oh it is it is
dare I say better than average sex
it's way better than average sex like
great sex is hard to beat but just you
know run on the Middlesex like sober
morning pound one out sex
there's a moment when you're riding a
horse so there's like three speeds okay
there's a a walk there's a gallop and
then there's a Cantor and then there's a
run gallop's a little painful it's just
like boom boom boom boom I've done this
really sucks and then a Cantor is like
and then when you yeah you get that
horse going there's a moment where
you and the horse become one you become
one the horse uh the energy of the horse
Takes Over your energy and dictates what
you do and there's a moment where your
body and that horse's neck are going at
the same that's me on that horse that's
my horse and you're going at the same
rate and you're [ __ ] flying
it is the purest Joy I've ever had where
I wasn't it's like a roller coaster but
but even more dangerous because you're
like and you're just smiling ear to ear
and and my hat flew off my hair is in
the wind I'm like yeah yeah I didn't
realize I was super about to get hurt
John's like slow the [ __ ] down
really yeah because I was out of control
I was completely the horse was in
control I wasn't in control and did a
horse's know to stop or keep going uh
you so you got to stop with your your
legs your legs your ass you got to put
your ass into the back of the horse so
he knows hey we're done because if he
doesn't if he feels you up in the stir
UPS he's like yeah [ __ ] let's open this
[ __ ] up this is what I was meant to do
this is my natural speed the way I drink
at airports is the way horses run yeah
that's when you see me at a full clip at
an airport and they're like another one
I go yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm in Gallup
mode baby that is where a horse [ __ ]
like I mean just [ __ ] show a horse
run into full speed it's so beautiful
and you'll see what I'm talking about
the neck does this and you get into this
symbiotic moment with your horse where
you become one it's the coolest thing to
have an animal what a half a ton between
your legs
and just be this that's a that's a car
oh no they're doing a horse okay does it
make you does it give you anything see
okay so that's like a that's a Cantor
okay and then do you see the way the
neck yeah kind of just look at the neck
and then you're going up the neck's
going down and then you guys meet back
up again at the same place it's almost
like it really is the best rhythmic no
feet on the ground no feet on the ground
you're just flying oh my God this is
what a horse was meant to do anything
against this is against that animal
horse man to run at full speed that's
why it's that's why marriage just
doesn't make sense to me at times yeah
it's for not for me because it is
because I'm I'm out to pasture I'm old
horse you think so I like to run but
like my running's internally like like
last night starts with my wife is
[ __ ]
yeah dude my wife and I got into that
moment into that [ __ ] are you on the
back or the bottom or what
I was on the bottom I was on the bottom
wow but she was like Leanne was playful
fun she was drunk playful fun crazy
[ __ ] and there was a moment where
you're just you're both moving at the
right time yes but like for some guys
I've had some of that before some guys
some guys men are meant to Sprint some
guys mentioned my buddy Croy he was
meant to Sprint he was meant to be out
there that's his way his brain works he
just can't stop doing sex out there with
strangers uh well yeah I mean women that
he gets yeah women that he dates I mean
he's dead now so but uh yeah yeah but
because he was a [ __ ] horse everyone
wanted him to be a [ __ ] Pony and he
was a [ __ ] son I mean I don't know
look I love the guy I'm missing a ton
but some guys are [ __ ] sprinters you
know don't try to [ __ ] I used to have
a bit about it about how women catch
horses or maybe it's misogynistic now
but they catch you and then they you
know like because you just like running
on top of mountains
lightning striking and then these
settlers just staring up at the mountain
going I'm gonna give me that horse yeah
and then they come up with a bag of
carrots carrots [ __ ] and they're
like you probably heard this joke before
and they're like hey come here and
you're like blow jobs
and then when they pet you
so when you the really interesting thing
about horses
so horses like this is kind of crazy
this blew me away but horses are are out
in past like when you go when I every
morning I had to have to go get my horse
so my horse would be in a [ __ ] field
uh-uh and so I you have to go get your
horse and you whistle or you just go
over there hey boy hey boy and they like
it and you bring like a carrot or an
apple and he'd be like
they don't know they're getting caught
right they don't want to be caught
and he just comes over and the way you
catch a horse is you throw a rope over
his neck just throw a rope a rope over
his neck boom he's yours my wife did
that to me just threw a rope over my
neck I didn't even know I was caught I
didn't even know I was caught next thing
I got two kids [ __ ] five mortgages
I'm caught man I can't run anywhere
that's true huh you're done I'm done I'm
cool with it I'm cool with it was there
a point where you ever thought like hey
if I'm gonna get if I'm gonna get back
out there I gotta get back out there now
I remember that moment we were on the
beach
or the beach and she said hey
she'd dumped me and and I knew very
acutely that I needed her in my life and
so I won her back I made like a mixtape
I made a mixtape I wrote a letter I
cried in my shower I cried in my car I
cried everywhere yeah went on a run-up
running I was coming down Outpost by Ben
Affleck's old house and uh and the sun
was setting and it just rained and I
said to God this is what we were talking
about earlier and this is a hint on who
I won on my podcast I said to God if you
give me this woman I won't [ __ ] it up I
won't cheat on her I won't misbehave I
won't like I'll follow whatever I'll be
a good man I'm I I'll learn I'll go to
therapy I'll do all the [ __ ] you need me
to do to be it like the guy she wants
and I got back to my uh my house and she
was sitting on my bed in a sundress no I
swear to God and I went oh you're
[ __ ] listening I was like hmm careful
what you wish for right I was like
because then you're like so we talked
right we go to dinner out at like some
place in Malibu
I have a panic attack at dinner just
tell my daughter this the other day and
and then we went to the beach we went
out to Zuma at night yeah Zuma sat there
and she said I'll take you back
but I need to know that this is going to
be real
like that that we could like this is
going to lead to something and I
remember at that moment it's like it's
the natural horse Instinct where you go
yeah like wait should I run
should I run or just stay here with the
carrots and the petting
and I was like
and I thought to myself if I walk away
there's other there'll be another check
is that is the hopes of that better than
this and I thought about it and I was
like nope this is the best thing I can
get in my head that sounds cheap but
this is the best thing I uh that's ever
come in my way
like just a good person like I don't
want to miss this yeah she was like
she's all the things you could ever say
about I never say about my wife the one
thing I know about my wife is she's a
good person she cares about me she cares
about like she's selfless like real
selfless like uh I'm pretty
self-centered I said to these girls the
other day I said you know I bust my ass
on the road
for you guys and Leanne goes no you
don't
he's like yeah no you don't I don't
think
has anything to do with anybody else
it's you she goes you're because I was
supposed to not work in December and
then I got offered Alaska and I was like
[ __ ] y'all do Alaska and she's like
you're doing that for you you're not
you're not like winning Christmas
presents you're doing it because it's an
arena in Alaska and you want to go
snowboarding for a week and I was like
oh yeah I do this all for me she's like
it's all about you you're not doing Red
Rocks for us you're doing it for you you
you do pot like like I'm [ __ ] she's
taking the dog to the vet she's like you
want to go I was like I gotta go work
but I want to be here with you because
you made me laugh so like I'm like it's
he does nothing for her she does
everything for us so and I need that
teammate oh yeah you're a partner in
crime that's my lab partner yeah yeah so
she's my Hillary Clinton yeah
yeah that's a bad example but she's
hotter than Hillary though yeah way
hotter
um it's a good hint yeah what else is
going on I haven't seen you in a while I
haven't seen you in forever I know I've
just seen you on social media and you've
been so busy man it's crazy I was gonna
name my tour the relapse tour no yeah
are you serious yeah I got a lot of [ __ ]
for that did you yeah because I've never
been in recovery so some people are
pretty sensitive about that oh yeah I
can see that maybe and so he was so
jealous no I'm sorry yeah I was I just
was uh because I started the birdie Boy
tour and then um and then it got
canceled because of covid and then I did
the uh I did the drive-in movie theaters
and I I loved that one hot summer nights
is a great I love that title of that
branding I love the everything the the
bus what it looked like it was so fun it
was so kind of like 1980s bright colors
and then when they're like hey you gotta
rename your new tour but you gotta let
them know that their tickets are still
valid for the old tour you know some
people were like uh one for the road or
back about you know whatever ever and I
just thought oh relapse would be great
not thinking that there are that
recovery is a pretty serious thing there
were some people that were upset they're
like hey man that's no [ __ ] joke and
I was like no they're all jokes to me
if you hear what I really talk about I
was being serious on that one
no no I've never done
I've never done the whole recovery thing
and uh did you ever think about it
because you go I mean you go pretty hard
you know I think about it all the time
yeah I mean the problem I have is uh
the problem I have is that what happens
is when I feel like I'm going too hard
there's this internal kind of uh
metronome in me that goes it's time to
slow down it's time to you gotta let's
let's do a couple nights off let's you
know
and not the way like a regular person
would go like we'll just drink on
weekends you know and I'll be like I'll
just I won't drink Monday Tuesday you
know Monday Tuesday Wednesday or like
it's gonna sound like this is gonna be
the most
horrific statement you'll ever hear me
sign a podcast trust me but like or or
you go let's let's not drink on private
jets you know like that's like if you
brought in a private jet to get yourself
to work maybe you should use that as
that really expensive plane ticket as a
time to uh recovery and and work hard
and read a script and not just part of
your [ __ ] dick off like I have the
whole time I've ever gotten private I
get on private jet and I'll be like if
I'm paying 13 000 30 000 whatever I'm
paying for a flight I'm partying my
[ __ ] dick off we're eating Edibles
we're [ __ ] like yeah I'm gonna
[ __ ] get [ __ ] wasted oh dude and
then and then I started going no I
should probably not do that I should
probably use this as a time to work on
my business because it's a business
expense technically
so yeah so so but I always think about
it I think about there's a hint of term
who my podcast cast would be I think
about I was just a Vatican and I think
about I I
had this epiphany
to everyone has their God right so like
Rogan's God
I'm not speaking on behalf of Joe but
like from my perspective from the
outside perspective his God is
anti-aging right like so everyone's
worried about death so what are you
going to do about death to make you feel
better when you wake up in the morning
well for Rogan is taking care of himself
it's working out hard uh staying sharp
reading listening to audiobooks and and
so it's all the anti-aging [ __ ] he does
polar plunged uh sauna stem cells uh
um walking hyperbaric chambers yeah
thinking yeah walking and thinking or in
there but and so
that's his God yeah right uh siguro's
God is money and nice things and blood
doping whatever sugar is into I don't
really know
Ari's got his drugs is is mushrooms and
psychedelics and Molly the Shadows yeah
and and and dark traveling so like
everyone's got their God and then some
people we know that growing up their God
is really God they believe in God and
that's the thing that gets them through
their day is they take a minute and pray
and then I was like I was like well and
so like all our friends were did don't
believe in the real guy well don't
believe in God but do their own God I go
what if I just added a little bit of
real God to me like what if I tried to
find what if I legit what if I legit was
like open to Faith Like open to like
maybe something
maybe because I was at the Vatican and I
have like I have all the
like the crosses and the the medals for
the Saints
I genuinely love your brain I love your
brain you make me giggle so [ __ ] hard
oh thanks
so much this morning for the long time
trying to stay off vaping so are you
really yeah really Jesus brother
you know how many people women are
vaping man uh yeah children I mean the
whole families are laying in their bed
at night [ __ ] clouds of smoke yeah
leaving chimneys people think it's like
that it's just a warm home inside or it
looks or they think that uh someone
opened a mummy's casket and the curse
got passed on everyone
yeah I uh I never Vaped oh I mean vape
marijuana but get out of it out there
um okay so what else happened
so I'm in the Vatican and I'm like
beautiful
it's really beautiful
it's uh We snuck a little thing of
salami's in there too when we went for
real yeah I'm just nibbling on it yeah
there's no food summer sticks you know
bring up that summer sausage do summer
sausage is good it's kind of it's kind
of a deceptive name too yes summer
sausage Rogan gave me some summer
sausage oh it's so good man bring up a
stick of that God it's good and you do
that with elk you gave me a summer
sausage with elk
[ __ ] and I didn't know what it was I
tried to cook it and I was like I don't
think this needs to be cooked damn a
huge I feel like if you you bite into
that a Warp Zone will open up in your
local butcher shop dude that [ __ ] sounds
insane huh but look yeah we would nibble
on that while we're walking through
there we got a couple of these I
couldn't even have a water you couldn't
I don't think so because I think they
don't want people watering down the art
or watering down the statue yeah because
we did the whole tour like we did
Sistine Chapel all the artwork and then
yeah I don't think we had any we could
have anything to drink and then at the
end we were [ __ ] starving we were
[ __ ] starving and we're buying and
we're buying uh merch they do sell merch
like that like it's funny we were buying
merch and uh and George and I are like
I'm about to eat my [ __ ] flip-flop
and I was like yeah let's let's go get
somebody and so we went to we had a
really
shitty actually launch
and we want it looks like a pizza place
or something yeah it wasn't even good
pizza yeah that's the worst it's that's
one of the worst things about being a
tourist in another country everything
looks like it's perfect because of the
setting yeah and then you realize that
you're like you know just some kind of
just run at a mill joint yeah Italy a
drink
perfectly in Italy oh wow
perfectly I mean so here's my thing with
drinking if I if I Day drink it [ __ ] me
up I can't Day drink really so like I
can only drink I need to have that's why
the road works well for me because I
don't have my first drink till like
midnight oh wow yeah yeah so I'll drink
midnight till two whenever bus call is
maybe have a pop on the bus not lately
because I have acid reflux so usually
you just have a couple drinks you know
after the show two or three drinks and
then on the bus go to sleep maybe hit a
vape pen
let a joint go to bed and and I'm out
listen to a podcast I'm out and then
wake up the next day a little late but I
don't drink the whole [ __ ] day so
that's really good for me because day
drinking if I that's why I don't drink
on Jets or drink on planes because I if
I Day drink on a plane then it goes out
throughout the day and then that really
puts a dent on your on your on your
Wellness like you just feel like [ __ ]
your sweat smells like piss you're shaky
your piss smells like sweat
no your sweat smells like piss too both
of them yeah both of them I mean when
you're in my balls smelled I drank all
day yesterday [ __ ] uh started it like
seven so you just did it yeah yesterday
but I but I busted my ass in the gym
today so it got out of me yeah but uh my
balls smelled the worst anyone's balls
have ever smelled in their entire life
when I got in the shower to come here I
took a little dab and sniff and I was
like
whoo that's worse than armpits oh that's
[ __ ] and that was that was booze so
how jealous do you think the front the
the how jealous do you think the back of
your balls are of the front of your
balls dude
well the back of your balls hang out
with your [ __ ] the front of your
balls hangs out with your dick yeah I'd
much rather hang out with a dick than an
[ __ ] me too imagine just being back
there it's like living in the slums it's
like
it's like a
so it's like it's like I'm trying to
think of two Comics one a dick and one's
an [ __ ] would you want to hang out
with
uh
maybe Dice and uh wait which is nice I
mean you can fit either way probably
dice could be a dip but that's also his
brand though yeah but it's like an
ironic dick right right yeah he's an
ironic like he's uh he's he's just who
likes being a dick Jizzle Nick kind of
is he a dick I don't know he's just kind
of morose I think he's just quiet I
think he's just a I think Jeselnik is
like a Justin looks like Segura they
don't need to talk to people I need to
talk to people I have talked to people
I'm gonna stand outside oh Tom doesn't
he's kind of he can do his own thing huh
he could not speak for the rest of his
life I think other than on stage and
he'd be very happy wow he does not need
to speak like he does not I get into a
car with someone and I am chitty chatty
Kathy yeah the whole ride yeah you're
really you like to be alive I love being
alive it's like my favorite part of
being alive is loving that you're alive
right like if you just kind of go I'm
alive
you know there's times where I'm you
know there's times where I'm I wake up
and I'm rough this is when we're talking
about like the recovery brain of like
man what what should I do and then
I think the difference is I wake up and
if I feel a little down a little
depressed maybe a little hungover maybe
a little shaky from partying too hard I
go you have two options today you can
lose today you can lose it you're
allowed to you're allowed to take a
Xanax Tap Out get back in bed crank up
the AC throw on Netflix put it on a
Spanish-speaking cooking show and just
go to sleep for the whole day you can do
that or you can choose to win the day
where you get up you have a coffee you
Barrel through it you go to the gym you
work out and you just ignore that voice
in your head that goes hey man we're not
going to be able to do this today you go
I'm not listening to you today I chose
to seize today and and and knowing for
me knowing that I have that tap out of
like hey we can call it a day we can
wake up and call it a day make a
breakfast sandwich eat a Xanax watch
Netflix crank up the AC blackout
curtains sleep wake up at eight and have
a cocktail with your wife and have a
great [ __ ] day we can do that or we
can push through the day we can get up
early we can go have a coffee we have a
treat maybe a little bit of Instagram a
treat you know a little yeah and then
get in the gym push through it piss
sweat in the sauna in the polar plunge
and you will feel better you will feel I
promise you you will feel better and
what do you choose I always choose the
the one where I work out I always choose
it I've choose I've chosen
Xanax before I have right I have my wife
always knows it and she's like oh it's
so funny I thought you were different
than that but you just gotta you gotta
choose to not listen to that voice in
your head that's going we can't do this
man this is too hard like you've ever
gotten up
I think that's where some people
struggle with like alcoholism I think
that void it's not even sometimes about
the drugs alcohol it's just about that
voice the next day and how much it like
haunts them or like how much it like the
drugs Now call fuel whatever the
negative feelings like it just it's such
a gasoline on those thoughts and
feelings do you ever feel like do you
ever feel like maybe and uh by the way
we don't have to keep this in if you
don't want to but do you ever feel like
I always wondered with you because I
know you're sober do you ever feel like
maybe there was just aspects of your
sobriety maybe there was aspects of your
partying they should never have been
included yeah like cocaine yeah like
that should never have been in your mix
right and you should have never been
introduced to it and had you never been
introduced to it you may be able to have
a few beers with people I'm not saying
by the way I'm not I'm not oh I want you
to I want your happiness you want to
think about that every day you are you
are a joy to listen to literally
honestly a treat when you come up I I
I it's funny who your kids like right
like Georgia just thinks you are [ __ ]
the cat's pajamas you make her giggle so
hard Isla's a big Tim Dylan fan that
makes sense right and Dylan's great but
like I don't want to [ __ ] with either of
you or Tim sobriety but you ever think
that way oh yeah cocaine I can't do it
it [ __ ] me up so bad that I want to
quit everything yeah I go [ __ ] it it's
like the next day off of cocaine I'm
literally
um I'm literally waiting for the stroke
to hit I'm going like it's coming right
now it's coming right now why did I do
this why did I do this to myself yeah
it's like that no whammys like that game
show yeah oh whammys no whammies it's a
heart attack God damn it my heart's
racing dude yeah cocaine's just insane
man if I'd never found cocaine yeah I'd
never had any problem with anything else
is that crazy so sometimes I think maybe
at some point I would just not do
cocaine but yeah I mean it leads to it
yeah that's the problem is it's once you
once you find out you can once you find
out you can just turn around in the
media and go the other direction on the
highway it's really hard to not do that
every time yeah like if you never knew
if you never knew you couldn't do that
yeah when people were like yeah I I and
then I realized why I never even super
enjoyed drinking because cocaine you
like I can get messed up right now
right now and marks get go you know what
I'm saying it really does it really is
so much better than a shot it's just
like it's like and I remember the first
time I ever did cocaine I was in New
Orleans and uh and my buddy had a rock
and he had a screen of a damn this makes
me want to touch my [ __ ] dick even
hearing about it he told me he was one
of my best friends to this day one of my
best friends and uh he said I we were
looking for uh ecstasy and he said I
don't have any ecstasy and I said but
you're partying right and he was like I
am the same age uh
and he goes I and what do you look like
a white guy a really good looking guy
more Italian more looking like
Michelangelo
um you know you know Michelangelo's name
wasn't Michael Angelo it was in one word
it was one word and it was and that was
part of a bigger name I thought it was
Michelangelo not like Michelangelo
Pizzeria uh Mussolini that's a black
Italian I think if it's the full one
yeah
it's amazing there aren't more
michelangelos anyway
he he said I have cocaine and I said I
said you I remember going you do you do
cocaine and he goes I I yeah we do
cocaine he was like and I was like is it
safe and he was like yeah it's totally
safe he goes here's the deal look me in
the eyes and he said
it's really good and it could become a
problem and he goes in it it has for
friends like trust me and I was like
what should I do and he goes he goes you
got to make that decision on your own so
I went off to my buddy who I was looking
for Ecstasy with and I said we can't get
XC but we can get cocaine and he was
like he's like I'll do it and I was like
I was like I've never done it he goes
it's it's pretty good and I was like
really and he was like yeah
so we went back I said I'll do something
didn't have to buy it he just gave us
you know I grew up with a kid and he
shaved it off of the screen of like a
window it was a screen it was a screen
that was on like a a tilt so it was like
two sticks yeah with a screen that went
like this and it was maybe this big
that's Carpenter's cut dude that [ __ ] is
good he shaved it off of that and it
feathered down
and he cut a line and uh he said snort
half of that with one with your nose and
I swear the whole thing with one nostril
yeah and he goes that that's I think
you're good and I went okay and Theo
immediately from this tooth over and
this tooth over went ice numb the whole
side of my face and I went I was like
whoo I thought woo and my first thought
was I I remember I could walk outside
and rip a tree out of the ground and
carry it around tonight
but I'm so smart that I won't do that
because if they see me with a tree
they'll go he's on cocaine so I'm not
ripping trees out and then I was like I
think I'm gonna need to do the other
nose because this side isn't numb and he
was like okay just a little one and he
gave me another line and I did the other
side and this tooth went sing I mean I
could hear it Go
and it went all the way over there and I
said uh I looked at my buddy
and that might oh I won't say his name
the buddy I was partying with Ron and uh
close and so I said to our other friend
I said I think I think we're gonna go
down to the Bourbon Street and he was
like okay he's like he's like no cell
phones he's like we'll see you later and
I was like great and I looked at my
buddy and I said let's go have some fun
we took a little bit of pouch with us
and we had one of the most exciting
nights of our lives and and and maybe I
don't even think we did any more cocaine
throughout the night I think we maybe
did a key bump maybe yeah but I don't
think we did any more and we had a
greatest [ __ ] night of our life and
then that night went back passed out my
truck
woke up when the sun was coming up with
the most acutely searing anxiety attack
I've ever had in my life and we had an
eight ball left that my buddy gave me
for to take home and and we had to drive
to take home yeah yeah and so I took the
eight ball I put it in my Cherokee we
drove from New Orleans to Tallahassee
and all my brain did was like I hurt my
brain you know you got regular brain
where you go
hey maybe we should pull over and get
McDonald's and your little regular brain
regular little guy you've been with your
whole life and then you go oh that
sounds like a good idea and he's like I
just thought I'd put it around bring it
up yeah and so I get in the car and
little brain's like dude we still have
that cocaine right and I was like yeah I
put it in the it's in the middle and
he's like are you sure that's a good
idea and then all of a sudden this this
[ __ ] anxiety voice goes what the [ __ ]
are we traveling with cocaine dude we're
going to [ __ ] jail what the [ __ ] you
need to pull over right now you need to
hide that in one of your bags either
that or do it we gotta do cocaine
that'll make the drive so much better
and I was like should we get food and
he's like [ __ ] that we've got iron
stomach we can't get our dick hard and
we can't [ __ ] let's drive drive it was
like Sam Sam Kinison was in my head and
man I I tell you very candidly I haven't
got rid of that voice forever that's why
I don't [ __ ] around with cocaine is that
[ __ ] voice the next day all that fun
that was it's not worth it to hear that
guy yeah just we better get out of bed
you're on blood pressure medicine what
the [ __ ] did we do last night
you know I've needed mental health uh
therapy
good God I needed it
hell if if mental health there if they
had a swim team I would join it
because all damn backstroking my own
feelings all day
if you need help or mental health
therapy or considering it better help
might be the solution
that's right find a therapist that can
help you become a better Problem Solver
making it easier to accomplish your
goals no matter how big or small better
help is convenient
it is accessible affordable and entirely
online get matched with a therapist
after filling out a brief survey and
switch therapists at any time I've
needed better help I wasn't doing well I
was driving and I was not doing well
and driving
and I pulled over and got help right
there
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o to get 10 off your first month
that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash Theo
you know it's impossible to cancel
subscriptions
you know I had a subscription to
something I don't remember what it was
it was a um
a Cane Company walking canes and candy
canes one month they send you a walking
cane and next month they send you a
sugar cane so you was eat you know
getting sweet and you were um
you know taking care of a limp or
something or helping a senior
but damn it's impossible to cancel the
subscription
so I got canes showing up everywhere
just it's it's gotten ridiculous
it's just it's not fair to have to
cancel everything and they make it so
hard they trick you they scamming that's
why I love using rocket money formerly
known as true bill that's right you can
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
Theo
seriously it could save you a hundred
dollars a year hundreds you know you
might have a subscription of this to
could be Netflix or uh you know
gummyworms.net or whatever that you
don't know
you could have said marshmallow
subscription
and you just your whole mailbox is just
all fluffy bunied out you can't even get
any mail and just nightmares
so you got to take care of yourself and
take care of your subscriptions rocket
money can help rocketmoney.com Theo get
rid of useless subscriptions with rocket
money now go to rocketmoney.com Theo
yeah man that thing that that's the
thing it's like you don't want to fuel
that voice because in some people that
voice is already kind of uh like
animated yeah and so yeah sometimes
people are drinking to shut that voice
off right and then and when you sober up
that voice goes he's just hear him wake
up like what the [ __ ] did you you tried
to kill me with alcohol last night oh
Welcome to Hell [ __ ] let's check
our dick we got genital warts
yeah dude I mean that voice that's why
Xanax is so great Xanax I never had no
Xanax oh Xanax just grabs him real quick
like a [ __ ] Gracie grabs his ghee and
goes like this good night good night
you're good tonight in bed now and he's
like crap can't breathe can't breathe
and then all of a sudden Xanax comes you
come out of his Xanax and you hear that
voice and he's like he's like how long
have I been out for
and you're like all right you're good
man just lay there for a little bit lay
there wake up and he's like okay
holy [ __ ] what day is that and you're
like it's Thursday and he's like no [ __ ]
what are we doing this weekend like
don't worry about we're gonna have a
drink later tonight let's just shut the
[ __ ] up and he's like
dude I got [ __ ] up last night what
happened It's like because my whole
thing's shutting that voice down by the
way I'm sure there's someone who runs a
Recovery Center that right now that's
like oh Bernie's going to recovery
tomorrow
and by the way we need to can't get rid
of this podcast you've just got everyone
back on go game
I don't know man well these days also
cocaine got too dangerous to even do so
it's like funny now one of the things
that keeps me from doing cocaine is
cocaine because it's like it's not it's
just there's no reliability with it like
I remember uh
uh trying to convince somebody like oh
this guy gets legit cocaine and like
where does he get it from and I'm like
no you're right
he drives a [ __ ] Dodge Neon okay I'm
sure it's good dude look at this [ __ ]
line in his hair
look at his fingernails they're
pedicures we're good you know I got some
I have some friends I won't say their
name
I won't say their name and I hope
they're watching because I want to say
their name so bad because they're Comics
if I have some friends I was partying
with and we're like hey you want to get
some cocaine and I was like I'm I'm
turning 50 in November that shit's way
out of my [ __ ] I don't know it's
risky it's why there's no reason for me
to do it there's nothing there's no
benefit I I know and so I was like No
And they got it and it came with a
fentanyl tester oh yeah they're selling
fentanyl testers but how can you test
every little grandmother can you bring
that up can we see what that looks like
I don't know they I don't know but I'll
tell you one guy went to the hospital
wow yeah it's really dangerous
um but yeah for alcoholism do you think
that you're an alcoholic no I've been
I've run it through the ringer a few
times Dr Drew's my litmus oh yeah and
I've talked to him about it he's like
you're not an alcoholic you just drink
too much it's like alcoholism is
different being powerless to alcohol is
different than drinking a lot yeah and I
think same with like I'm a guy like Ron
White I think he was a big drinker I
don't think he was an alcoholic because
he just quit yeah I think he was like
you know same with Nick Swardson Nick
sports is just a bit or I don't think
Nick drinks anymore but he was just a
big drinker I don't think he was out
however powerless to it he's planning on
drinking again oh for real oh go for him
Nick has the best story dude Nick's like
bro I was in Denver oh he almost died in
Denver
no he did tell that oh God I was just
like here's how I just felt like he was
almost died you know they they [ __ ]
banned it they put him in hospice they
had a police come in and go he's pretty
tried to molest him too
what do you expect dude if you're going
into hospice and you call a priest dude
somebody better touch it can you imagine
how bad it would be to be have been
molested by a priest and then be on your
deathbed and the priest walks in you're
like great the one thing I've tried to
never remember my whole life thanks for
bringing it up why don't you bring in a
snake I'm scared of them too
oh my god dude that's got to be so true
man but Nick was so great he's like man
if you drink in Denver Beware of the
Alta he's like you got to drink water
the altitude will get you he's like I
was drinking for six weeks at a motel
and uh the out I'm like the altitude
isn't the it's not the altitude it's the
motel once you put the motel in there
yeah
you're leaving you're leaving Colorado
he's like dude if you're gonna drink in
Phoenix man the cactus is there yeah you
know did you know there's a lot of cats
in Florida do you go down to Key West if
you're drinking anywhere near the
Hemingway House there are cats your
allergies are kick in and you'll die
from drinking yeah you go to the
hospital man oh so funny dude he's not
drinking know no he's been served for a
while man good for him but um he had a
couple cities that were like on his on
his fear list but I think that's well
that's the truth it's like you know if
you it's like I don't think Dr Drew is a
great litmus test he's really really
awesome about all that stuff I'll tell
you right now no one comments on your
drink and if you're skinny when you're
fat and I've been really fat I kind of
still am that's when you get people
showing up I had a week where I had
three people tell me they were worried
about me but they were just worried
about me because I looked like [ __ ] and
I was fat I was 265 pounds I told
someone I told someone the other day who
was I talking to so it's 265 pounds and
he goes 270. I went no I was never 270
he goes yeah you were you just didn't
know it wow because once you weigh
yourself at 265 going I look good today
and then you're like 265. that's [ __ ]
fat well there's days you're 270. and so
uh I think three people reach out to me
and go hey man I'm worried about you I'm
concerned for you
um one of them counted two of them
didn't
um and that didn't count but right but
you're like how do you know I was like
you haven't been around me you just saw
me one time and you were partying with
me and and and and by the way you're not
my wife you're not my best friend like
if Tommy says to me I'm worried about
you then I listen right but like
so yeah but uh and I lost my lost like
20 pounds and uh and then nobody said
anything no one said anything lately not
probably partying just as hard as I
always have you know yeah I mean I
thought you were gonna die before but I
think that it's I will die yes so you're
gonna win that one but I think it's
because
um
I think it's because you go so hard like
you just have I mean it's just whatever
you've always had I'm like a lot of it I
think is also Envy I'm like how does he
keep going
watching his social media feed is making
I'm tired like I'll go I'll see three
three reels a Year's on Instagram and
have to and go get a massage you know
I'm saying I'm tired it's like wow how
does he keep going I don't know I think
it's the thing I I think uh I don't know
I think I'm a little bit of a holic it's
like I'm I'm a holic of a lot of things
but not full-blown like I'm a workaholic
I'm a workaholic I'm a workaholic
hardcore and I think maybe that's where
I put my aholism in is in like a healthy
place but it's not healthy it it it
pulls from your family and your your
your sense of well-being and yours and
but like I don't mind being a workaholic
because I feel like you only get one
especially now because you only get one
opportunity to shine so you get an
opportunity to sell some tickets
in my opinion you you better be on the
road trying to sell some tickets if you
if you pop you know like if you have a
moment and you pop
and people go I want to see that I want
to see what that guy's like live you
know they will forget about you so you
kind of got to go out and be like I'm
here
um I trust me I took two and I took two
and two months off and I was off social
media pretty much like I remember I was
[ __ ] around with it every now and
then but there were days where I'd have
like two stories up and I'd forget I'd
skip a whole day and and I and I had to
remind myself you have to go back to
work like you need to get ready to go
back to work and I I could very easily
be like everyone else and go like
yeah man I think I'm just gonna do
podcasts you know and and I'm not and
not push it as hard as I do
but I only got one opportunity I'm not
gonna live forever and and I definitely
want to make sure that my family's
comfortable and I and I I love stand up
and I love podcasting I love my cooking
show something's burning I love I love
two bears I love being I love all of it
I love [ __ ] around with Joe on me on
social media and taunting them and and
hearing the text I get back from I got
five texts from Joe in my pocket and I
get episode like sober October's getting
ready and so we're [ __ ] around and
challenging each other I love that [ __ ]
I love that but I love all of it I love
you know I love
taking in content as well it's like well
you love getting up every day I mean you
really love being a lot you love it I
love being like being a lot like today's
a great day today is a great day yeah
today's a great day I woke up it uh I
woke up at six
woke up at six caught up with Leanne we
had great sex last night so we just kind
of caught up and what is great so you
guys are doing the great sex so it's um
and you guys now as you get older do you
have to do it for a long time is that
matter it's a lot quicker oh wow yeah we
get each other down
right so like uh like last night she
last night last night
the the the horse was already panting
okay like she was she came in bed
looking to fool around and does she do
any does she like turn a plant a certain
way or like light a candle or like do a
leave a chocolate or something no she
smiles and she's playful and she's so
Leanne's like a little bit of a book she
bad at that wiener like a cat no no no
no no no no no not a woman do that she's
uh she's uh she's a bully so like she's
like in bed and [ __ ] with you there's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah what was she saying
last night that was so funny she kept
going uh
let's get that dick out tiger she wants
to say that
well if she was doing something that was
funny but it's bullying me and so so she
gets in like a like like a almost like a
fun bully mode let me burp that worm
homie or something like that yeah gang
gang yeah yeah yeah that's it dude so
she but she was fun last night and then
I was like all right and so we started
messing around and and uh when when we
started I was like oh she's here to part
like she got drunk last night she never
gets drunk George had to drive us home
Leah never gets drunk never gets drunk
she drank a bottle of Rose by herself oh
if it's Rose dude somebody's giving head
and Sh and man
it was like you know
you ever been so hungry you you get uh
Kentucky Fried Chicken and you don't
know whether the start of the mac and
cheese the mashed potatoes or to eat
some chicken yeah and you take it by the
chicken then you start before yeah you
have it all in your mouth before you
even have any of it down and you don't
even know what you're tasting yes that's
what sex was like last night like just
sloppy drunk KFC too we all doing oral
too or no oh back and forth and oh and
it was just it was all of it and
Leanne's really good at [ __ ] wow
that's awesome really really really good
she's really like she's Next Level she's
next [ __ ] level yeah a lot of women
uh especially from a smaller Community I
hope she's called me saying that
oh I think it's admirable I just I
forget I'm doing a podcast I'm like yeah
she's really [ __ ] good oh I think
it's admirable you don't I mean there's
nothing I think it's because you grew up
in the South and most of her family
can't read that's why they're good at
blow jobs oh dude if uh
yeah I bet you got Ken who could [ __ ]
suck like nobody's business
like a third cousin or something dude is
this crazy to say this bro now I wonder
if this is crazy is it sometimes it's
like
I'll be talking like
uh like have you ever talked do you have
what kind of siblings do you have two
sisters isn't it weird sometimes that
they've blown dudes before does that
ever seem weird to you uh you know like
yeah and uh
I don't think about it right I don't
think about the act of it but like that
they have done it right the other day I
was talking to my sister and I'm like it
just hit me and then I was like oh my
God
she's like old enough to have been
blowing dudes and everything
yeah I got two sisters and she has three
you know she has two children and stuff
but the old uh same same mom same mom
same dad really yeah
how older sisters you're the youngest
right yeah there are they yeah they're
in their 30s so it's so funny wait wait
older sisters they're younger okay yeah
they're younger and you're like they're
in their 30s the other day I forgot I
was like you said to say something wrong
and then don't correct yourself and
you're like yeah I'm turning 40 next
month and everyone's like and now no one
could listen to anything I said after
that I'm like
are you gonna go with that I was like
yeah right I was like I mean 50 I'm
turning 50. so that's so funny I always
thought you were an only kid for some
reason I was always thinking you had
only kid energy
um I could see that I always felt like
an only kid I like distanced myself from
my family right out of the gate yeah you
did didn't you yeah it was just like a
budget program over there I was like I
want I want a profiler to figure your
brain out because you got energy no
one's got you you got you know what you
got you got I was hearing a story about
a man uh from Hawaii I won't say his
name only just out of respect I was
hanging out with his son and uh they
said he left home and he was 12. and
then you got that and the guy's very
successful very successful in Hawaii
um Game Changer [ __ ] Next Level dude
you got that energy you got Oprah energy
we're like you go
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
get there I'll make it I I don't I'll
I'll get through there
you yeah you got you're an interesting
dude well thanks man yeah I think you're
an interesting dude man I I definitely
always get envious of your ability to
keep going it's like and yeah I think
that's where I think people think you're
gonna die is because they're like oh how
can they keep going but then I think
there's just some people who just have
the ability to keep going like do you
feel under like insane pressure by your
own schedule yep I was saying that to
when we've talked and you were like
how's everything I said it can get very
overwhelming at times very overwhelming
especially because I've set myself up
into a scenario and I'm not I'm not
complaining at all I want to be very
clear it doesn't sound like you are this
doesn't sound like self-pity or anything
so two years a year ago two years ago no
I think just a year ago today yeah cause
I'm going Red Rocks next week
next week you just did it like a year
ago I did a year ago I'm doing it again
wow so Red Rocks was the one thing that
kind of changed my career to a tad bit
I mean you know ticket sales you know
what we can move like we're all in that
same spot where we can move maybe 5 000
on the markets pretty safe to say 2 000
a market five thousand a market do a
theater
um and so and and I was supposed to do
red rocks with Tim Jeffries he had a kid
and he had to back out because he was
his due date was on the day we were
supposed to do the show and they said to
me hey man
we can try to find another headliner you
can do it by yourself no we know
I said me and you I and I could be
really wrong about what you're I think
you may be outselling me but like but
like 10 000 tickets in the market is a
lot that's an arena act and and I'm not
in a I wasn't at the time an arena act
but I took I liked the challenge like I
liked the idea that no one thought I
could do it and I liked the challenge
and I went and and I knew there was I
knew there was no foul if I didn't
because I was already supposed to do
with Jim so I knew that it was like a
get out of jail free card I could take a
swing right and tug the tiger's tail and
see if I can knock him out or and blame
it on Jim and his kid yeah and if I fail
I go oh I'm supposed to do a gym but I'm
glad he had a kid I'm glad he's happy
and so I took the challenge and I
challenged myself to sell Red Rocks I
did a lot of promo videos uh I had a
soft announcement because I was in
Serbia doing the movie my social media
numbers were slowed down because of the
way all those countries look at the
Eastern Bloc and so they just I was
getting like 25
000 views on anything I put up I
couldn't and so I had a soft announce
for Red Rocks
but when I got back to the States I just
hit it hard on a promo video after promo
video I didn't stop thinking I didn't
stop working and I went into surgery to
get surgery on my elbow from hurting it
and ripping my tendons off in the movie
I went into surgery and I said I'm going
to use this everyone counts this is my
way my brain wouldn't just shut off and
I said everyone counts backwards when
they go to sleep not me I'm going to
read a promo date I'm gonna be like
ladies and gentlemen I'm performing Red
Rock September 13th come see me and then
right and so I rolled into surgery guys
like what music you want to listen to I
was like CCR baby Credence yeah and we
went into surgery my arm was numb I
dropped the phone once the phone once I
threw it up my anesthesiologist is like
what are we doing I said I'm doing Red
Rocks September 13th October 13th
September 3rd whatever September 13th uh
I'm gonna be there the night before
Jimmy Buffett I'll be a Jimmy Buffett
he's like you're going to Jimmy Buffett
I go you want to go I'd love I'd love to
go and he's like all right you're gonna
feel this and all of a sudden I'm gonna
and I dropped the phone on my chest and
I went into surgery but and then I sold
out Red Rocks I sold out red rocks and I
said it to my team I want that challenge
all the [ __ ] time put me in venues
like put me in venues give me the
opportunity I I I had a change of of a
change of perception after Red Rocks
because I hung out and went to Jimmy
Buffett and we hung out in Red Rocks
that's us at Red Rocks last year
and what was amazing Theo is do you
remember though you'd hear those Comics
that would be like
don't ask me when I'm gonna come to
North Carolina I was just in North
Carolina and they'd blame the fans and I
was like why are you blaming the fans
it's your fault they don't know you're
the reason they didn't come to your show
they you didn't tell them you ish the
onus is on us as the performer to let
our fans know that we're coming there so
that because they wanna they wanna I
like I have friends in Tampa who are in
love with you they want to see you it's
your job to let them know and by the way
that's where we come in you post it and
I go oh [ __ ] my friends in Tampa want to
know that's why we're you know Rogan set
up this great workaround of us helping
each other out and and letting our
friends know oh [ __ ] deal is coming out
uh Samurai has a great special on
Netflix it's not it's our job to help
bump up Sam Shang Wang special on you on
oh yeah that's coming out it's [ __ ]
awesome when your special came out I
must have tweeted about it or text it
about it or put it on Instagram three or
four times because we all watched it we
were in Austin and we were [ __ ]
laughing hysterically and that's that's
the job of our community to lift each
other up but it's our job when I went to
when I went to Denver and and Evergreen
and all around Morrison
not one person that was in that City
said what are you doing here
everyone said I tried to take a show I
couldn't come hey how was the show Bert
hey I was at the show it was amazing not
one person we went and looked at uh
Boulder Colorado for my daughter to go
to university Colorado yeah
all the kids on the campus how was the
show at Red Rocks Bert [ __ ] the ticket I
couldn't get the tickets it was too late
Bert it sold out before I get tickets
that's what you want and so I thought
okay so if we're talking about promotion
I get promoting once is one thing
promote your tour that's great if I go
I'm gonna go into every Market where
there's an available seat and I will
Hammer those markets until they sell out
or until they start pulling curtains
back and and I S and then and then I got
and then they said uh I said I want to
do this thing fully loaded I want to set
up with 10 comics I want to get three
tour buses I want to do outdoor venues I
want to do Arenas I want to do baseball
stadiums I want to do all this and
they're like these are these are Big
tickets this is twelve thousand fifteen
thousand you know venues and I was like
don't worry I got this
and I challenged myself I said I'm gonna
challenge myself and I and I didn't ask
any they were all great every comic that
was almost amazing they helped repost
they helped talk about it they help sell
tickets thank God Nikki Glazer Chelsea
Lynn Mark Norman Shane Gillis Dave David
tell Big Jay oakerson uh Fortune themes
Dustin Nickerson Taylor Thomason leave
me something they all retweeted they all
reposted they all did special posts but
I said it's all me it's my tour I
created this Festival I will [ __ ] and
I've got a editor in the back of my bus
I had another editor and I put out
content daily and EV and you watched
those people just going oh they're it's
just commercials it's just commercials
and and uh we set record attendance in
in a ton of places that was a cheat code
because you know technically a baseball
stadium can't sit people on the infield
right so we said record attendance but
but you know whatever so yeah but but I
I looked at uh I and I and so that that
challenge when I did Red Rocks first
time it changed the way I worked so I
went I want to I want I want to prove it
to myself off I want to I want to go
bigger I want to go harder and so I just
don't shut my brain off for stand up and
I don't shut my brain off for promotion
and I don't do a lot of television shows
because it shifts the way you look at
things I love podcasts and I think I
have a list of things I talk about on
podcasts I think I love doing a podcast
I thought about stuff I wanted to talk
to you today about and I and I love that
energy of going I get to hang out with
with a guy who everyone that's watching
right now everyone that would love to
sit down with for an hour and a half
everyone watching
would love that opportunity and by the
way I'm a fan also I watch you all the
time so I'm excited so literally it's
like
if you said anyone what do you want to
talk to Theo about you're like I know
what I want to talk about and I write it
on a list on my phone I go to do rogue
and I write it on this it's fun getting
the opportunity to do Rogan yeah that's
enjoy yeah it's crazy it's like getting
a surf with Pro Surfers yeah I mean
today he looks you on me it makes you
look amazing yeah you know and so so I
think I'm very blessed I don't look at
any of it as work
I just go like yeah man I'll [ __ ]
push it till the wheels come off and
they'll come off they'll come off
there'll be a time where I'm like I
don't know man I don't know maybe I'll
just die look I die in a plane crash
they never came off I just died I'll be
a [ __ ] Legend he died in a plane
crash yeah tour bus accident
not as much I think so I think that
plane crash people respect that 25 000
feet you went through yeah you know and
then wondering what he was doing the
whole time on the way down I'll tell you
what standing up drinking Jack Daniels
going [ __ ] it if it's your time to go
it's your time to go and I'm cranking up
Freebird Leonard Skynyrd if I leave here
tomorrow some people would chime in dude
and I'm hoping I'm hoping that that
coward buckled into the back yeah tells
that story man he went down that's
Ronnie Van Zant went down like that
[ __ ] Freebird the plane's going down
and he just Ronnie put your seatbelt on
stands up follow Jack if it's your time
to go it's your time to go now in
hindsight if you want to see probably
survive but but that's that's true I
mean yeah definitely because everything
everyone lived but him
but uh do you uh haven't done uh I know
you did your movie
um do you think cause Bobby and I just
got offered a television show right and
so it's like what is the reality the
time commitment and everything is huge
though yeah I would do
I would do another movie
I would I like that time commitment I
like that I have like a couple projects
lined up
I would do another movie I really
enjoyed that process I have to be a
producer on the movie and a creative
part I can't just I can't be an actor
yeah I can't just sit hire me and I need
to be a part of the team that helps make
the thing make make it good make it
funny yeah yeah I like that um I like
giving notes to other actors too
uh like I really enjoy that I like the
process of making something it's really
cool um I would do a scripted single
camera
um and that's it I scripted single
camera television show I do a multicam
like a sitcom I think I'd really I I'll
tell you this and this I'm putting this
out there I'll sell out and do like a
legit cheesy kind of bad multi-cam if
you give me like 15 years I do it in a
heartbeat if they committed to 15 years
you mean by the way or you mean 15 years
from now like if you tell me like if you
tell me like I could get amusing bad
examples but like if you tell me I can
get uh
um like a just a regular sitcom where
it's like uh a bird has a cow or
whatever it's called you know and and
then every I have like a cow that I
talked to him I he like sticks his head
into the kitchen windows yeah and I'm
like what's up Mr Cow he's like you're
gonna have a rough day today yeah I was
like really and he's like I think
you should talk to your wife she was up
cleaning the dishes last night really
upset and I was like you're the only one
that I'm the only one that can hear you
right he's like that's right I'll be in
the backyard and then my wife comes in
she's like how you doing I go I'm just
helping with these dishes yeah secret
cow
yeah like that would be a I'd do that
show called having a cow or something
like that yeah yeah don't have a cow oh
that's it don't have a cow and then I
got a cow that maybe no one sees and
it's in India too and they like the cows
are Gods though and all my dude I'm so
attracted to Indian women oh yeah that's
why I have an Indian wife Indian
children I live in India hello husband
husband yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that would be great you want some
spice yeah oh I love Indian food too
sprinkling in your [ __ ] mouth huh I'm
the only one that can see the cow I do
that by the way if you're a screenwriter
and you want to write that up I'll I'll
do that
it's a common heartbeat he'll do it yeah
I mean it'll just
I I mean I can't imagine what the second
season would be but I think the first
season will be [ __ ] good you know I
go vegan oh
I go vegan and the cows and the cow's
like this is what I'm talking about yeah
uh did you like do you like do you like
acting
we I just did a part in a movie with
Bobby and it was fun man it was nice
because I knew the amount of time
commitment okay that's where I get
[ __ ] up that was a big thing like like
I'd gotten all uh to do that move with
Chris Pratt a couple years ago where he
gave me a part and that it was I got
there and got to read the script and I
saw I didn't have a lot of and it was 12
weeks I was like I can't do it just it
was too much for me to commit to okay
this was only 12 days okay so I was like
oh I can handle this you know how do you
feel this is I'm I'm probably outing
myself as like
as as
not a team player but how do you feel
when like a PA goes just go to your
trailer I'll get you when when we need
you does that bother you oh I like going
into that trailer oh I can't stand it I
want to be on set really and I go I'll
just be on set and they're like actually
we can't have you on set and I go
actually I don't hire on the [ __ ]
calls you than you are actually I'm
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] I want
actually I busted my ass for [ __ ] 25
years to get to this point and you have
just have an older brother who got you
this job and you don't even know what
the [ __ ] do
sometimes I feel like that oh yeah I
think well that's the problem with going
to do acting is you have to be under
somebody else's like jurisdiction and
their thoughts and feelings and then
it's their words and it's like like this
movie this this movie I did was just it
was a friend of mine who had written it
he knew and it was like if I couldn't
communicate with him as clearly as I
wanted if there was any like he really
expressed like a real like owner [ __ ] I
would advise I couldn't do that like did
you meet Chris Pratt yeah I met Chris
Pratt what's he like oh it's super nice
I think that's what Jesus would have
looked like nice and clean oh yeah right
he looked clean man I bet he smells good
I didn't really smell him I party with
his ex-wife once really yeah
I didn't smell it but he was really nice
really affable and uh I felt kind of bad
about leaving because it was such a neat
opportunity what was the movie it was
called Tomorrowland tomorrow War oh that
just is that been out it's been out yeah
it came out during the pandemic well it
was what's tough about you in my opinion
is I'm sure people try to write for you
and put you into something and then go I
got Theo's voice but your voice is so
authentic and so
kind of kind of
comedically swaggered in in any attempt
to write for you is just is almost like
a parody of you if that makes sense like
if you try to write for Mitch Hedberg
you'd be like you'd be like
hey man I'm high as [ __ ] and you're like
well that's not Mitch Hedberg that Mitch
never talked about like you know right
he just was who he was yeah and so like
it's it's
it's hard to write for your perspective
that's what I think it would be tough to
like write for you but that's why it
makes sense that what you enjoy is
collaborating and being like I'm gonna
put I'm gonna put my spin on it yeah me
and Spade just for wrote a movie
together so yeah I gotta call did I tell
you I had a dream about him yeah he told
me about that yeah so maybe uh so that's
been exciting to me because it's
thinking like oh well I already know
what's gonna happen called Spade in
Manhattan
it's called
um it's about being bus boys oh for real
yeah it's about adult male bus boys
David Spade's one of the coolest
[ __ ] he's funny he is like yo
man that generation of SNL guys how were
they so much funnier than what is on
like how is like Kevin Neal and like all
how are they why is there such a
different level of their like
improbability do you feel like I I was
thinking of that today I was you know I
was thinking
I wonder if David Spade ever looked at
me and goes wow my best friend was the
biggest influence on this guy like this
guy loved I like I loved Farley Farley
gave up Farley showed us a way to be
funny when you didn't know how to be
funny you didn't know how to be
comfortable with yourself he just showed
you that being large being in being
being being vulnerable this like he
really honestly like I wonder how often
he goes into a comedy club and goes well
this guy was a big em my best friend was
a big so on this guy my other best
friend was a big influence on this guy I
mean how much of us like you look at
Shane Gillis you go huge influence on
Shane girls is Norm Macdonald right
normandale's a big influence on all of
us want to Spades best for I mean like
Spades and he's so cool
you know when I I [ __ ] up this
interview with Adam Sandler really bad I
don't know if you ever saw it it was bad
not as bad as that Greg Louganis when
you did
nope
I was just [ __ ] pretty cool dude yeah
found me out bro that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
pretty good you made me laugh the
hardest that day in your tribute to
Amelia Earhart
that's the hardest I ever laughed well
that [ __ ] gets all this clout that [ __ ]
went missing you know what I'm saying
bro
[Music]
okay
oh if that was a dude no one would talk
about it wouldn't say a word
uh
wouldn't say a word
oh yeah Ronnie [ __ ] up yeah that's all
they would say Ronnie [ __ ] up
but they let her they just you know it's
that Title IX thing man oh that's Title
Nine
oh god dude
um no I [ __ ] up that Sandler interview
it was so bad what happened
had you met him no I've never met him I
never met him and and I'm obviously Adam
Sandler Adam Sandler David Spade Norm
McDonald Chris Rock Chris Farley that
generation
is their thumbprints Forever on me like
Chris Rock stand up bring the pain yeah
he's my favorite it's the it's
it is the thing I watched where I said I
want to do that like that I don't I'll
never do that but that's what I strive
for that that strut he had on stage
Stop I mean everything was like a bull
whip like Jaw and it was so jarring of
so amazing and then Sandler the way
happy he developed all these great
movies that just spokes the price is
wrong [ __ ] yeah you can do it like all
these like just a way to take like your
inside jokes with your friends and make
them inside jokes with the world and
then you know Spade was such Spade Norm
Dennis Miller a little older but like
Kevin Nealon all these guys they're just
so so influential on my sensibility so
Whitney hit me up and said hey you know
it's a pandemic
she's like yo we're doing it I'm doing
an interview with Adam Sandler
uh you want to come by my house and and
if you want she's like I would love some
help interviewing Sandler you know such
a [ __ ] star so if you could just come
and we'll figure something out for a
podcast no no no for uh
we're raising money for Comics that need
the money for the pandemic so I go over
to Whitney's backyard I kind of [ __ ]
around in the backyard I'm I'm messing
around I'm on I'm on YouTube yeah I'm
doing whatever the you know just to make
it fun make it Interactive
and then she goes to interview Sandler
she says come on in we're gonna
interview Sandler and I I got my heart
was racing and I got and then he just
pops up on the screen he's like hey
and Whitney's like uh Adam I'm here with
Bert Chrysler and he's like okay
and I
went
full [ __ ] [ __ ] for dolphin full full
baby walrus like just like
and I
talked for about 10 minutes he I don't
think he said a word and I just said
everything wrong you talked for 10
minutes I said do you have Netflix and
Whitney's like huh and Adam's like I'm
sure in his head he was like well I just
I I ran what I was do you have Netflix
um uh I can't wait to see your new movie
precious gems that's not the name of it
um I just showed my daughter's and I sat
and watched Happy Madison that's the
name it was production company not the
movie we watched um hey you want to hear
a cool story about when I was in college
and he's like huh and I was like when I
was 22 years old I got voted by the
number one party animal in the country
you ever told in that whole story I did
all of it I did all of it sorry man I'm
sorry I vomited I vomit and Theo I
thought it went well I was like nailed
it that's alcoholism left Whitney's
going coaching you need the closer bring
in the closer you Adam Sandler's
probably going who the [ __ ] is this
Burke Chrysler guy signed him to a deal
covert get Chrysler on the line This
Guy's hot we need him first person to
call me was uh first person to call me
was uh Big Jay oakerson and he goes he
goes hey man just letting you know we're
going to trash you and I went huh he's
like we're on the zoom next and we are
crying laughing and I go oh what and he
goes that Sandler interview I go good
huh he goes good
he goes you asked him if he had Netflix
I'd go do I do you think he doesn't and
he goes Bert he has a 300 million dollar
deal at Netflix he definitely has
Netflix I went
huh he's like you call this movie
precious gems I go that's something Amy
goes no it's uncut he's like you named
the movie Happy Madison it's Happy
Gilmore Billy Madison Bert we are going
you didn't let him talk it's the biggest
movie star in the world and you didn't
let him talk and I went I just started
going like it was that bad and he goes
I'm we're going online right now we're
going to trash you and hung up and I
went huh and then my buddy my buddy Mike
um apps no no no uh does podcasts with
Greg Luke Valentine nope anyway uh Mike
Mike God damn it he's he does the
podcast with Martin does a podcast with
Greg Fitzsimmons they do Sunday papers
uh oh Mike uh vecchion no anyway he
calls me and he goes that [ __ ]
Sandler interviews epic like I told him
I go have you seen my new special my
special just dropped it's called uh it's
called Hey Big Boys dude I was out of
control I was out of my house Stone
sober Stone sober out of control so this
is why Spade's a cool dude right
unprovoked I gotta [ __ ] you know
Spade sometimes voice texting oh yeah
and he's like uh Chrysler
[ __ ] Sandler interviews epic and I'm
like I'm in bed going the next day going
I'm gonna have a drink today this is the
[ __ ] worst day of my life yeah this
is the Xanax day and he goes hey man I
talked to stanler he just watched your
special he [ __ ] loved it dude he
loves you you're the best we all love
you don't sweat it and I was like
I like by the way didn't need to do that
right didn't need to do that didn't need
to leave that message didn't he let me
know hey don't worry about it you didn't
[ __ ] it up that bad then I signed a deal
with the Happy Madison to do a movie wow
yeah so like everything worked out great
like going to have Happy Madison uh
pitched a movie I think yeah yeah and
then uh signed up to do a movie so
everything's like everything worked out
fine but like man I that interviews you
can find it online
yeah I can't wait to watch that when I
get cringy I'm not even watch it in the
car dude yeah I'll tell you this uh the
um I went to uh Spate I ran out of gas
the other day I was going over space
right he brought me
gas really
he's a nice guy yeah he's a really nice
guy yeah how much money do you think he
has he's got a big heart
um
I'll say a name tell me if he has more
than or less than that name
okay okay
British harp
more than
um
Rosie O'Donnell
less than
because she went pretty core she was
like on the okay Beto O'Rourke
um
but more than
more than uh Hunter Biden
oh
probably a little uh of his own money
yeah Spade yeah
um I don't know what do you think those
got I mean I don't know I think Spades
got 25 million dollars
that's what I was gonna say he said he's
had a number of very successful movies
yeah he's on sitcoms oh I bet he's got
way more he was on sitcoms forever he
did that one he did um don't shoot me
yeah but no I think that's dude I'll
tell you this story so I went with Owen
Benjamin right okay to he took me to a
happy Madison party right I've never
been before and this went vaping nah
marijuana had just come out yeah people
were vaping it you know and I thought it
was a cigarette I hadn't seen The Vape
in marijuana I'd just seen The Vaping
cigarettes so I'm out there smoking with
somebody out front
um I think it was like Dave Becker
somebody had like a vape and cigarette I
don't even know I couldn't tell you what
Dave Becky looks like I couldn't I could
probably draw him for you but I I
actually might even negative I know Dave
Becky so well like I know that name I
know that I know who he is but I've
never seen him in person that's Louis CK
that's Dave Becky
did I say Becky it might not be dead
I might be talking about the wrong guy
okay keep going so anyway uh let's take
a hit off the cigarette I didn't know it
was weed so I go into the party and I
start meeting people from
the Adam Sandler movies oh and bro I
didn't know that I had smoked weed and I
hadn't really I'd probably been in
Hollywood maybe three years maybe yeah
so I start meeting these people dude and
I start losing my [ __ ] mind and I
start thinking I can't handle meeting
famous people oh for real like I can't
the more people I meet the weirder I
feel I can't even be in this city like
this is my first time meeting famous
people because it is it is hard you got
to learn how to meet famous and the weed
was hitting I didn't know it was weed
yeah so I'm Feeling High I just didn't
realize it really so I'm feeling like uh
[ __ ] up and I'm like oh man when I
meet famous people I'm I just I feel
[ __ ] up
I can't I can't live like this in this
city but if I meet [ __ ] Mark Wahlberg
I'll [ __ ] take my own life or
something you know like I just didn't
know how bad it was gonna get I saw Mark
Wahlberg when I first moved to Hollywood
walking down Sunset Boulevard
uh with a white T-shirt over his
shoulder like a I want to say like a
Yankees cap on or something or a Boston
cap on and jeans just [ __ ] strut I
walked right past him I was like Marky
Mark and he's like nah no way yeah maybe
it wasn't him and that's that's why that
guy said no but I thought it was him
that's when he was changing his whole
Mystique huh I think so yeah yeah the
the crucifix tattooed on his chest and
everything I got scared I ended up
dancing with Sierra once on the dance
floor yeah she's a musician really and
um and I got nervous and uh I was too
stoned and I had to go sit out my car
I got nervous I had a meeting at Happy
Madison when I was a kid you know young
in this business and I just got nervous
being in the building because I
was a I thought I might run into Adam
Sandler it was back when I think they
were on like the
Sony lot or something and uh
is that I think they were in Culver City
and I there was like a basketball hoop
outside and I thought I was hoping I'd
run into Knicks I knew Nick worked with
them so if I was hoping that I'd run
into Nick and they'd be like oh Bert let
me introduce you Adam and I'm like oh
cool and then I'd be like what's up Adam
and he's like oh dude you're [ __ ]
hilarious oh by the way I wasn't I
didn't especially at the time I wasn't I
don't even know if I am now and so I
went in and took the meeting
with one of his one of his development
execs and the guy goes it's a great
pitch he goes why do you want Adam to do
it and I went
I just want to make it and he goes can I
give you some advice I said yeah he goes
focus on your career I was like what do
you mean he's gonna write the movie for
yourself make the movie for yourself you
should do it yourself he was Adam was
sitting here he goes it's a great idea
you should do it and I go yeah and he
goes that's how he did his career you
need to focus on your career you need to
work on yourself it's a great pitch he's
like I mean I guess we'd buy it if
you're done doing things for yourself
but like your comic like you should do
it for yourself I went okay and uh and I
and I nothing happened to it I sold it I
think I sold it to Disney uh with Will
Smith attached well Nick Cannon was
attached but Will Smith was going to
produce
would you take a break now and do a
television story you're saying you would
do one down the line
uh I wouldn't take a break I can't to
not take us what would you but if you do
a TV show you there's it's just the time
commitment you have to like SK you to
have to skills you know you can't work
12 hours a day
I uh yeah I I wouldn't
I couldn't she couldn't do it I have uh
I have uh
uh yeah like huge huge chunks Europe
Australia booked out for next year I
have a huge Chunk in between that and
then a big run at the end and uh yeah I
couldn't do it you know I I've also I've
often thought to stop doing specials
um because that that process of doing
specials it can be a tad bit
overwhelming because I'm a little bit
obsessive about putting out a good
special and yeah and I mean I watch
everyone special watch everyone special
for two reasons I want to see if they
have if I've if I'm stepping on anyone's
material and I and I like to see how
people do things you know I'm gonna pay
you a compliment I hope you're cool with
this but like
you you I learned a lot watching your
special and I learned what I don't do
sometimes is what you're so brilliant at
and I'll never be as good as you but I
can work harder on what I don't do and
what I don't do is I don't really tell
you the characters sometimes I just
start telling the story hoping you know
the characters you set up you paint a
picture of a character or a scenario
you're about to hear so brilliantly so
brilliantly that I literally I remember
being on the [ __ ] road driving to two
bears one cave in an Escalade with my
whole team and I was like listen to what
he [ __ ] does like I'm playing it back
on this is like this is like there's no
one better than you at
you can set up you can set up a story
so brilliantly where I go I want to hear
that my problem is I just start telling
the story sometimes I go I need to work
on like creating the characters being in
the moment being slower you know because
I I think as I tell sometimes you know
13-minute stories
I just start going let's go let's go
let's go hey thanks for the thanks for
the comment man it's really sweet of you
I'm envious of the way that you I feel
like I have to catch up to you sometimes
and it's that's more fun I feel like I
feel like your style is so much more fun
it's like here I am in the middle of the
[ __ ] action like with me it's like I
feel like you have to go to boot camp
you need to shine your shoes you have to
go to bed and get up early with you I
feel like I [ __ ] open my eyes and I
am on Normandy [ __ ] beach dude and
who knows what is gonna happen that's
the best compliment I've ever made right
there in the [ __ ] that's a great company
you always seem very present man and
that's one thing that I really admire I
think that's why I take my shirt off so
I remind myself that it's supposed to be
fun like that's why I did it the first
time would you ever go fully nude do you
think yeah I would have you thought
about it
no no yeah yeah I have there's a show
that's fully nude anything in New York
and uh I would definitely do it I would
I have no problem being naked I don't
even have a good dick would you wash up
first or not uh I'd probably trim up I
wouldn't trim up I don't know what I'd
do
I wouldn't wash up would you wax your
butt
uh-uh I wouldn't seem oh they would see
my butt in my current oh they would
unless you walk off the stage backwards
like that you could do that on the stage
and walk out like a hostage I bet hair
on my butt dude so like if I was with a
chick I would always walk out
yeah oh I don't have air on my butt
cheeks not a bunch but like almost like
this but without the little prongs yeah
I have hair on my a lot of hair on my
[ __ ] oh yeah and so
um I wonder if you can see it my ass is
starting to look like a sad like it use
I have a great I take that back
something better I think because I've
been running a lot it looks better when
I was gaining weight my ass looks sad
like I got a I did a video of me naked
and it just didn't look right and I went
ugh I was getting old man ass and now
I'm back running and lifting and doing
dead lifts I think my ass is back yeah I
took a video of my ass in Hawaii
and it looked good looked really good
how nice is Hawaii uh it's the best
place in the world God you know what I
did I'll tell you this is a I don't
really share this a lot of people
because it does sound a little a little
bit no no no no no not at all not at all
I even feel about saying I go to Hawaii
oh I feel bad that people have never
been to Hawaii I actually said to my I
said to my wife we stayed at Turtle Bay
it was [ __ ] gorgeous yeah and I said
you know what I'm bummed I have
experience I have a lot of had a lot of
great experiences in life one of my
favorite experiences is taking my
daughters to Hawaii take them into the
ocean letting them get snorkels and go a
little deeper than they're comfortable
watching them get scared and as their
dad taking care of them I love Hawaii
it's the greatest place on the planet
it's set up that Aloha energy is like
hello but it's also like get the [ __ ]
out like and so that's the whole it's
this and by the way their whole economy
set up so that you have the greatest
time you've ever had so that you tell
your friends that's it's like it's
amazing it's amazing shaved ice there's
nothing better to put in your mouth yeah
and so I bet if you put condensed milk
on a dick I love sucking dick so and you
ice it up you have to get a cold dick
and then so that yeah yeah all right
it's like a no warm dick
that is
it's either hot deck or cold dick but
lukewarm so uh so I set a goal I'm done
Tom braggadocious what I'm saying is I I
I'm it's very vulnerable okay so it's
265. no I've never I maybe I've said
this I don't know
did you feel fat it that way I've
no I love that I didn't even notice I
was fat like it just I catch a picture
I'd be like woof or like I had a hard
time we had a new couch and I had a hard
time like getting up like it was just
like this would be like you're not going
anywhere yeah it was like a big brother
sitting on your chest going [ __ ] off and
so uh
so I
I've wanted to serve I've wanted to
serve I served as a little bit as a kid
but like as an adult I thought this
would be a cool thing to be able to do
to be able to get a surfboard go to the
beach and and burn and for two hours
just burn like a thousand calories of
fun of fun yeah paddling and and just it
would be fun and I was like and to glide
on the wave I've only done it a few
times
but that feeling of gliding on top of
the ocean with just the ocean pushing
it's very it's a lot like riding
horseback yeah
so I set a 265 we tried a couple times
to get surf lessons and I could not I
couldn't physically get from laying on
my stomach to all my feet in enough time
that I needed to get up on the board and
so I said I made a goal when we took
time off I said I'm going to lose weight
I'm gonna lose enough weight so that I
can go to Hawaii so I booked the trip to
Hawaii for me my daughter uh my
assistant my cameraman and my sister
those two because we were all flying way
to go straight to tour so I booked a
trip for all five of us at Turtle Bay I
went to Turtle Bay because Jamie O'Brien
has a surf school I followed Jamie
O'Brien on YouTube I I know the guy's
legit I know that he makes surfing fun
and I kind of knew and I hit up a couple
guys like Nathan Florence and I was like
yeah that surf school was pretty good
yeah it's good break it's easy break and
those guys are [ __ ] awesome you're
gonna have a blast wow so I didn't I
didn't hit up Jamie I didn't tell him
like yo I'm coming I wanted to pay for
it because I wanted to I I wanted to do
it right I wanted to pay for it so that
I could do it so that so that if I if I
needed more time I I didn't feel rushed
so I bought surf School set lessons on
the first two days we were there for two
hours for me my sister my my daughter my
cameraman and my assistant No cameras
just all we're gonna do is learn how to
surf and for two months
every day I did a few exercises I did
this rev balance board to try to get
work on my balance but more importantly
I would do planks for a minute and I
would do pop-ups like Burpee pop-ups
yeah to try to get to the place where I
could get my fat [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
body off the ground like just literally
I would every morning just do like 10
pop-ups and just try to get up we're
getting your knees up to your stomach
that's the top it's like a tough part
and I got I had to lose weight to get
that get to that level get that Carriage
on you yeah that's why I got down to 245
which is you know very nice 20 pounds
less very nice and I was and I was in
I'm in really good shape right now but I
was two weeks ago so I was in really
good shape going in I hadn't Drank In
like 12 days or something but not for
any reason just because like because I
went to Mark Norman's bachelor party and
I was like I need a [ __ ] break and so
um
and so I went into Hawaii and that first
day I first waved they pushed me into a
[ __ ] bust ass and then I sat in the
water and I'm like this is not going to
be my trip yeah I was like I will I as
as much as like a little boy in a
[ __ ] 49 year old man's body I said
let's focus let's take our time we're
gonna get this so I went back my uh my
surf instructor uh I [ __ ] his name up
it's ik I a no it's i k i i k i maybe i
k a i k a is how you say it
he said hey man take your time this is
German isn't it no it's very Hawaiian oh
it is yeah yeah
you're thinking Ikea
I don't know what I was thinking that's
Swedish oh yeah and so he goes hey man
uh arch for a little bit longer and take
your time
so it pushes me into a big wave and I
arch and I take a breath I'm moving now
and then I just very slowly
get up to my knees slide my feet around
stood up and I was [ __ ] surfing and
I'm telling you I've had very few like
moments of like accomplishment and it
sounds crazy to say because I feel like
I've done a lot but like where you go
hey man I [ __ ] busted my ass in the
gym for two months I did the work so
that I could do this and I'm doing it
and I [ __ ] surf that wave
all the way to that next buoy and I I
turned around my daughter's cheering for
me my sister's cheering for me
is like that's right you did it you did
it and I served for two days four hours
the waves got shitty after that but four
hours I had of just being in the water
surfing and I loved it so much now
granted if I want to go surfing in La I
need a kaika to come out here and push
me into waves and Coach me and be like
Arch Arch Arch on your knees on your
knees front foot back foot bend down
your [ __ ] goes God damn it like I
need him like I'm not that good yeah but
I had a [ __ ] blast and I and I and
and uh and it was it was something I
wanted to do I wanted to I wanted to do
it I want it it's like you know wait
Rogan you're watching me to take up
these Hobbies he sucked at archery when
he started I'm sure but he was like I
want to be a Archer so you need that
moment of vulnerability I'm not saying
I'm gonna be a surfer but like you need
that motor vulnerability right where you
say I'm not going to be yeah you need to
crawl and it's so when you do when
you're at a place in your life where you
don't need to crawl a lot you go I could
just go do the road I'll do this I'll do
podcasts I'll do I don't I'll go ride a
bike I'll go to the gym I don't need to
crawl in front of people it's
embarrassing too being fat in the water
having a a guy 20 years younger than
you'd be like people looking at you big
animals coming by and yeah buddy yeah
and so uh so I went surfing Hawaii it
was [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] it was really
great yeah there's something magical
about it man
um you have me and Bobby do a TV show we
talked about maybe trying to shoot it in
Hawaii
[Music]
some fat guy who fails a lot I'll do it
just that it's a big time commitment you
know that's the thing I mean it's a
blessing to have the opportunity oh
doing Bobby would be fun do you want
Bobby living in Hawaii hi Bobby hi Bobby
and uh on my first episode of
Something's burning yeah oh yeah it just
came out just came out today yeah I did
a moment Andrew Santino back there made
tacos by the way that's that's when I
met really met Andrew Santino for the
first time yeah I never really knew
Andrew I knew of him and stuff but I
never really hung out with them he's
[ __ ] interesting man he seems like
he's living a great [ __ ] life yeah
he's in everything he's a great [ __ ]
actor great comic but every time you see
him he's like on the back of a boat with
a [ __ ] celebrity we're playing golf
with a [ __ ] celebrity we're like
doing like cool fun active [ __ ] and he's
in good shape he drinks but he's not
like he drinks like a regular person
because he'll get loose but then he's
like I got [ __ ] to do he stays active
man yeah he stays real active for a
redhead too I know they're not supposed
to be active well you know they stop
doing their sperm at the sperm banks a
while back no quit red-headed Seaman are
you serious
oh if I was Andrew Santino I'd get a wig
yeah
a fake mustache and just [ __ ] do it
for do it for your race yeah do it for
your people Red October two and it's all
October go to sperm banks and just bust
oh oh it comes out pink you know that
right oh I don't even tell it comes out
pink yeah well that one dude but I think
he was sick oh dude um I wonder what's
gonna happen with tiger belly if Bobby's
gonna be because if they
split up I think they're split up but
they're still co-hosts of the same
podcast I wonder if that's going to get
strange or not
I think about that sometimes
I can tell you what I'd do
Burn It To The Ground Burn It to the
Ground
bad friends 100 bad friends 100 friends
my friends I'd be [ __ ] I I'm not as
I'm pretty shallow if I was in that
situation
I was if I I don't know I would be very
I wouldn't be fun to work with really I
would not I'd be drinking all the time
if you're with a spouse you mean if
Leanne and I had a podcast like I'd do
Leanne's podcast every now and then but
if Lynn and I had a podcast and and uh
I don't know I don't know all the things
that people know I don't know everything
that I don't know what yeah I know what
I know what I know what I know and I so
I don't want to say too much because I
don't know what everyone knows but I
know what I know and I I know that if I
was in that situation of like of
splitting up and uh yeah could you still
work together right and and and I'm I
don't know what everyone knows but like
it seems in my opinion I don't know if
Bobby didn't want to be with her if she
didn't want to be with Bobby but
regardless if I was in Bobby's situation
and that was Leanne I'd be like I I I
would not be as and and I love Kyla
she's awesome but I I just I know if I
was Bobby I wouldn't be the funnest dude
to be around yeah I'd be every episode
would be about how my feelings every
episode will be about my feelings yeah
about how I feel oh this is my house
how this is mine it's gonna be
interesting but maybe that could be cool
for people it could be like a real soap
opera it could be it could be but I
don't think it's good for Bobby's mental
health yeah that's cool mental health
again that's what I wonder it's like
what how does something ha it's like
when you split up how do you stay
working together some people do it it's
very do it you got to be a bigger man
than me and I'm just not that big of a
man I'm very I'm very sensitive uh I'm
very uh
I'm very vindictive
uh like meaning like when when it comes
to feelings so you know like there's oh
yeah there's moms in our friend Circle
that I'll never give a second chance to
yeah they [ __ ] hurt my daughter
and I or or said [ __ ] about my wife that
um there's dads I'll never get a second
chance dude they don't know it I do it
behind their back because I'm [ __ ]
I'm hateful wow like it doesn't happen
in the business I mean sure I'm sure
it's happened in the business usually
people hate me like I don't hate people
like I have a couple people that hate my
guts and you just gotta go all right
whatever I don't care but like I don't
I'm not the best at like I'm not the
best at
like navigating those moments kind of
like if something is kind of very
emotional like Tom will Tom could tell
anyone right now and we've said it on
two bears uh I get my feelings hurt very
easily over very stupid stuff the
dumbest stuff in the world my feelings
would get hurt and Tom knows it and like
there's certain things like the dumbest
things to you like if we have a dinner
party
like where I sit sometimes can hurt my
feelings wow
and so and so and and I and I like if
they sit you at an end or something or
they don't say like what's that like say
like uh you and Brendan have a dinner
party right you bring checks
and uh and and then you have all these
guys here and they bring checks and you
invite me and Leanne
I expect to sit near you guys right
right like and so if all of a sudden
everyone's it could be a real accident
like every you guys sit on the corner
and then these guys all sit around you
and then me and Leanna at the end I'll
become a nightmare like I'll just I'll
be like oh but internally and you won't
know it at the time but then all of a
sudden I'll start like yeah I'll be like
so why do you work with this [ __ ] guy
with the beard and you're like what I'm
like I don't know man it's got glasses
on do you want a guy with glasses that
can't see the screen like that I mean
[ __ ] what you know like and and it'll
show up it'll rear its head it 100
happened within with nadav it 100
happened with indov and Tom witnessed it
happen and it was little things said to
me the wrong way I would take very
personally and uh
and yeah it's like a I think we're so
we're such trapped kids as comedians you
know I have to get past it and I have to
learn like I have to literally go
like it everyone that listens to two
bears knows that it happened with nadav
it happened when we first started
working together
I I I did not feel like I was a partner
in the situation internally because of
weird things like not in the devil say
that he was oblivious to right but I
would read wrong like
and and or or maybe he'd say something
and it would come up with too much
energy and I'd be like who the [ __ ] do
you think like and I and Tom saw it very
early and he was like hey man I know you
you it's not it's not what you think but
I was I was already there I was already
in the [ __ ] I was running the [ __ ]
well of blood just [ __ ] pouring on me
let me climb out let me climb out I'll
Savage and kill everyone yeah so
I wouldn't do well suck off an aorta bro
I would not do well on that wow so but
whenever you get in those moments and
you have these films are you able to
like start the conversation with
somebody say this is kind of what's
going on or do you get stuck in this and
that boiling I get stuck in the boiling
yeah I guess sometimes sometimes I'm
stuck in the boiling right now over one
person really yeah
in the podcast universe uh not really I
mean kind of but not really I mean no no
I mean yes
but it's a woman
I just need it
and so so yeah I have to I have to uh
learn I'll talk to Leanne about it I'm
in therapy
um better help shout out to better help
oh yeah totally dude uh that's good use
promo code burning the uh the but I have
to I have to work through it I've had it
bad and I've been able to call them and
talk to him about it or no I tried yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah some people yeah
some people I had an issue with one dude
and uh and I texted him and we texted
back and forth and I didn't actually
have an issue with the dude the dude had
an issue with me and I was like I want
to end this I want to I want to get past
this there's some people I have written
off like and I don't think of them like
I just wrote them off and I was like
that's that's that was a big thing my
wife taught me is that some people are
just dead to you you just gotta go oh
you're dead to me I I can't be your
friend the thing you do is a little
toxic and it [ __ ] me up and I just need
to stop right it's just not the best
relationship it's not the best
relationship for me and I don't want it
for me yeah and then there's people you
want to have a relationship with that
and that's the ones we're talking about
well you want a relationship with but
they hurt you and then and because
you're hurt you I end up you just laying
in bed and ruminating it it's called is
it ruminating or it's where you repeat
the thought over and over and over again
how you have the conversation there's
been there's been uh moms that moms that
there's been parents that have gave my
kid alcohol like that I just tell this
day burn it to the [ __ ] ground when I
found that I was like what the [ __ ] like
you know because there's cool parents
we're like you guys can drink at my
house yeah that's insane Thank you Lisa
molestation leads to people getting
pregnant
kids [ __ ] outside
thank you to that and because I'm the
guy that drinks on stage with his shirt
off and parties and I thought you'd be
cool with it are you out of your [ __ ]
mind hey I also [ __ ] my wife I don't
want you [ __ ] my kid like the [ __ ]
yeah yeah I I remember I got a blow job
one time behind like a real small tree
right this girl invited me behind a
small tree and we were young and pretty
dumb and we got busted man really yeah
and it was like just because there's no
way to really hide behind it you know
wait how old were you probably
13 14. you know
wow that's a really good job at a party
it was so dumb it literally the tree was
like this wide and we're like
you know doing a you know getting a
[ __ ] done
and the parents showed up and and that's
what happens when kids drink at houses
man yeah oh yeah I mean you just drink
when you drink and your your crotch
comes out like that's what like the fur
that's the PO that's the point of
drinking yeah it's like it's like I'm
not drinking to [ __ ] learn more about
you know yeah my daughter's not drinking
my daughter's not drinking because she
has ticket sales and in Alaska she needs
to move she's not drinking because her
numbers are low in Lubbock they're
[ __ ] she's drinking because she wants
they want to party they want to [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck a dog yeah [ __ ] they're
not [ __ ] it's not drinking because her
wife wants to buy another house there's
a [ __ ]
yeah so and so like I do I'll ruminate
over stuff like that but I've gotten
better therapy really helps because you
gotta you gotta let [ __ ] go oh yeah man
it's hard and it's best you gotta
realize other people are just living
their lives a lot of times they don't
even know what they're doing like it's
Old Wounds that we attach to like new
things that happen man oh it's been I've
been down that road you know we've all
been there yeah it's it's uh I feel I
feel like uh
I I said to my wife I I I said to my
wife very vocally a few a few months ago
I was like I need to like double up on
therapy
she's like what's going on and I was
like I don't know I think I'm I think
I'm starting a midlife crime like I like
the feelings of turning 50
um like is it fear like what do you mean
um no I just started realizing certain
things I started realizing like
actualizing certain things going like
[ __ ] man like
you know Tim Dillon said something very
very
uh insightful to me
I I was having a rough day and uh and I
I think no I think it was having a great
day but regardless I was talking about
you know sometimes that you wake up you
think of death that's the first your
first thought I'm like that's not cool
and uh and you gotta fight through it
you know and I and Tim Dillon said you
are at the height of your life it will
never get better than right now today
your kids are in that house everyone's
here the whole family's healthy they
haven't told you to quit drinking yet
you're making the most money you've ever
made you're doing the biggest venues
I've ever done you got a movie in the
can you got movies lined up you are
living your life today will never get
better in the future so seize today and
I went
um and I was like yeah
yeah
like death freaks me out and so I I
gotta try to push through death of like
again one day you die it gets undeniable
one day it goes black for everyone it
just goes black that's why that's what
leads me to the guest I want to get on
my podcast that you were trying to guess
okay so you know it's a person of faith
I know who it is then if you know it the
Pope no
by the way huge cat huge get the pope
would be [ __ ] great everybody's like
a person of Faith he's like Justin
Bieber you're so [ __ ] close
you're so [ __ ] close Carl Lentz I
don't know who that is
um it's a pastor Judas wait wait hold on
what does he do
the pastor yeah he's uh oh Joel Osteen
no I don't know the guy's name TD Jakes
The Hillsong guy
Carl Lentz is that him type in Carl
Lintz Hillsong Hillsong Pastor it's
either car the guy that the guy that's
Judah I don't know if Judith Smith the
guy that switched to Bieber
oh that's uh Carl hey I just texted with
Carl yesterday no you know him yeah no
way
you know that dude yeah so he's sweet
tell me about him because I don't know
anything about him all I know is all I
know is oh that's what he looks like
yeah so I I didn't uh all I know is that
he's like got faith right yeah I don't
know uh wait goth Faith got he's got
faith yeah Jesus believes in God right
yeah yeah he believes in God I don't
know a super ton about I mean I know
Carl
like I guess I don't know about a ton
about his history I know he had
um
I know I met him and Justin came to a
show of mine no in New York a while back
um
and that was the first time that I met
both of them
um I think maybe I've met Carl before
that I don't remember
but yeah I always thought I would love
to have Carl on too I think he's a super
neat guy we're supposed to catch up
sometime I know he's that's the hard
thing about being a man of the cloth is
you gotta live you gotta you gotta walk
the walk the of the talk you talk right
so you can't [ __ ] up a little bit
because then because that happened that
happened to um
to happen to uh to John Crist oh yeah he
got [ __ ] canceled for drinking vodka
out of a water bottle and trying to
catch a girl rollerblade
like because but it makes sense when he
tells you when he goes yeah man I was
lying to my my fans yeah I was saying
them one thing I'm really the other
thing he also got like a mistletoe
tattoo on his belly button near his
belly button are you [ __ ] serious I'm
joking
but um no Carl's Anika man yeah I'd love
to get to spend time I was like I was
like so crazy bro I was just texting
with him yesterday that's a guy I like
to get on my podcast I want I'm curious
about
how
I was talking to Bill Maher about this
about like you I'm saying if you could
get a surgery and and they would just
clip a little little
synax in your brain and immediately
tomorrow you believe in God believing
God 100 you'd be like
I get it like I get it I get it man I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm not gonna change my
life but I get it and there's an
afterlife and and I have faith and and
I'm it feels good to pray like you go
like I'm gonna pray a little bit like
every time I pray it's always like amen
don't let this [ __ ] happen you know
again hey man I know that was a lot I
didn't mean to take that much like I'm
going to sleep please make sure I wake
up in the morning stuff [ __ ] you know
like so I go those are my prayers or I'm
getting on a flight hey God don't let me
die hey uh I'm getting ready to go on
stage for this special God hey just
right last minute guys it's always like
it's always like I got out of jail free
you know what it's like it's like uh
it's like God from Pulp Fiction when he
calls Eric Stoltz and God's always like
break over prank call her and so like I
would love to meet a guy like this and
pick his brain and see if he can switch
my synapse or at least see if I can
figure out
couple of cheat codes like hanging out
with Rogan I don't do all the [ __ ] Rogan
does but do some of it I saw my Polar
Plunge I work out I don't do the [ __ ]
uh hyperbaric chambers and the [ __ ]
the all the [ __ ] stuff he does to his
body I don't do all of it like stem cell
I'm gonna do some stem cells yeah
shedding my skin for every six months or
whatever yeah when he goes and lays in
wax and then peels it off yeah him and
Tom they're hardcore like Lance arms
from talking about a dope throwing blood
now they dope their own blood in Austin
that's why they move there oh cool it's
because of the blood doping and so dude
I love clean blood now but I would love
to I would love to talk to that guy
open-minded like legit open-minded and
be like dude like how do you get there
like yeah what like what and look here's
the deal if I I hear he's not the guy
that goes
well first off you got to quit drinking
yeah like I heard he's like a cool dude
who's like it's like I mean you seem to
be doing good you know like let's figure
it out very practical I think if they
um I think that
well I mean I I've had
like I had no faith when I was a kid
except for like hypothetical faith of
like going to church and things you
would hear yeah but then as an adult
um I think a relationship with God is
just like a relationship it's like you
just have to work on it it's like you
pray a couple times a day you like start
gratitude well I started doing
gratitudes you put things in God's hands
you like recognize hey this is God's
will not my will today like it's it's
literally like a relationship it's like
a relationship with anyone the more you
check in with them and talk with them
the bigger the relationship grows so
that's all I think it is
um and then yeah once you have once
you're believing that you're not the one
doing everything that God is it takes
all the stress off of you do you believe
that I do believe that I've had that
experience in my life before really and
I mean it blew my mind well see then
then it blew my mind really because yeah
I was like oh this doesn't that's not
and then like oh wow this is to be
carefree and have your mind just be like
a vacant lot where
the present moment feels like it's just
loitering like instead of all over the
place oh I felt I felt a hard time
connecting with the present moment at
times where I'm thinking about the next
thing too much yeah or not even I'm
thinking my brain is thinking about it
it's it's I mean stand-up's kind of
defined on that like if you're in the
present stand up you're not thinking
about the next thing you're saying you
ever been on stage and you're like I
don't I can't believe they're laughing
and then you're like you're like I'm I'm
on to the next joke like I'm already
working on the next joke trying to think
of how it points that up yeah and so
living in the presence kind of kind of
difficult
It's Tricky well especially in today's
world I mean we're constantly getting
feedback from the past we're constantly
getting ju like looking at judging
things judging ourselves it's a really
it's an interesting time but no I think
a guy like Carl a guy like Judah Smith
those are uh TD Jakes those is all some
pastors that I think could be legit I'd
like to see Joel Osteen just as a
performer as a performer I would like to
see I wanted like I want to like I do
that when I go to shows I go to shows
I mean look I know people are gonna be
like do you enjoy anything Bert but like
I can't turn off the fact that I'm a
stand-up comedian who performs in in in
in in venues right so like I'll go to I
did uh I did the Greek and and and I
looked at the lineups of who they had
and and I was like I was like okay like
kind of curious of like like everything
everything I do is kind of like an
assessment I look at things from a fan
like okay I went to the Hollywood Bowl
against Steely Dan and so I I thought
because we do pre-sale for our tours
right and do you ever think to yourself
like what the [ __ ] pre-sale like I
don't even get pre-sale like pre-sale's
like it seems like why not just release
them on sale everyone's gonna buy them
anyway and then I went oh pre-sales for
your Uber fans because you got to use a
promo code and they're up here they
won't so I said
Steely Dan's coming to the Hollywood
Bowl they put him on pre-sale I bought
them at pre-sale so I get good seats and
I went that's what pre-sale's about and
then I said
how do I communicate this knowledge to
people listening right here here's how
pre-sale works
I ended up buying a whole box at the
Hollywood Bowl I ended up buying two
technically but and I filled it and then
I had the tickets because it's my night
right so if you're a theophy I want I
want to pitch you listening for a Theo
Vaughn experience right right now you're
listening going I don't get it he's
going to release here next door on
pre-sale uh promo code will be rat right
rat king rat king So when he releases it
you'd be the first one 10 a.m Wednesday
when those tickets on pre-sale
you create your night you want to have
because it's your present to yourself
you've busted your ass at the office all
week you're going to get to treat
yourself so buy say buy six tickets
right and get it you're gonna get great
tickets you're gonna even pre-sale and
you get them at the right price point no
no one's gotten in there yet these are
your tickets they're through the venue
you get six tickets and then you send a
text out that morning to the six people
you want to see that show with and go
hey guys I got tickets for Theo Vaughn
got them at a great price point I would
love to see the show with you guys and
then you get to plan your evening of how
your night goes you're going to see your
favorite comedian and you're picking
your favorite people to see them with
that's how it went and so I looked at it
like I went Steely Dan and I went I want
I want a box and I was like Well the box
is only like six people or maybe eight
people I got more than that I got two
boxes and then I went okay this is a
little bit of money but I go I got two
boxes and then I started a Steely Dan
chat thread right and I thought who do I
want to see this with Leanne my buddy
Tom my buddy Sandy my manager Judy her
husband oh I want my trainer Lacey to go
Lacey's roommates Antonio lapassa one of
the best chefs in all of La it's the
Hollywood Bowl we cater it ourselves oh
my God Antonia I love being with her but
she is the best chef in the world so I
hit up group chat hey guys who wants to
go to Steely Dan everyone hit up
immediately I love it I love I love it I
think I've paid for all the tickets I
don't know if I did or I didn't I don't
remember I don't I know I wasn't like I
need money but whatever so like we and I
got to plan out the next night so then I
go to Steely Dan and as a performer
right I sit in there that day and I go
um what am I gonna wear this is crazy
right Theo this is how crazy my brain is
and this is when you say you're a
workaholic this is what is wrong with me
I thought to myself what do I want to
wear to Steely Dan well I know it's the
Hollywood Bowl I know it's outdoors
um it might get cold later ooh I hope
he's selling sweatshirts right because
wouldn't it be cool to show up in what
you want to wear but if you get cold you
have the opportunity to buy a sweatshirt
wool Steely wool something something
something right and so I was like I was
like man I want to text Steely Dan right
now so I did on on Instagram I was like
y'all don't know if you guys are selling
sweatshirts at your show hit me up
because I want a sweatshirt and then and
then I I'm like and then I'm like okay I
look at beer lines I walk in I look at
beer lines I look at parking I look at I
look at all that [ __ ] as a thinks I go I
want to make sure that my fans have the
best experience of their life because I
want them to go uh that was awesome like
that was great and top to bottom I got a
sweatshirt I got a hat I bought a pair
of flip-flops like like I sold
flip-flops these these flip-flops fully
loaded my own flip-flop but then I
thought [ __ ] I need I'm technically I'm
asking people to show up Barefoot and
buy my flip-flops there and if I don't
know what their size are kind of [ __ ]
yeah and it's dangerous too to cross a
street Barefoot or to be in a parking
garage it's the truth man so but yeah I
look at I look at uh I can't shut my
brain off when it comes to wow to
touring I think of so many aspects about
how to make it a better experience but
that that pre-sale thing
your fans need to know because that's
the coolest thing as a fan of someone
and you need to remember that as a guy's
an artist to go like yeah let me get
tickets in a group let me bring people
that I want to be with let me make it
the best it's the best like okay who's
your favorite artist Morgan Whalen right
yeah Morgan whalen's pretty [ __ ]
badass right so um yeah whatever yeah
and so uh so if you so uh you get 10
tickets to take your 10 favorite people
around the world oh yeah who would you
go with
I'd probably take my sister you know
because she wants to go now remember so
that's your first invite so you're
catering around that because this is
your night it's gonna make sure everyone
meshes keep going and she gets bent up
too and she'll start dancing like oh and
it's really she's a mother too but
she'll literally put her arm on the wall
and just shake her ass for like an hour
I think I'm gonna like this keep going
keep going uh who else I'll probably get
my other sister to come and bring maybe
her son so that would be good
um I'll probably ask
um
I would maybe ask Baker Mayfield I saw
him we I saw Morgan Wallen with him
before him and his wife
so they like Morgan Wallen this is a
great group already you got family you
got friends and you got a celebrity
friend yeah and Baker had some buddies
that are cool that love it too so I just
said get up in a text to them I would
say bring up bring a couple of your boys
10 people from last time fun so now
Baker feels really comfortable your
sisters are excited they're getting to
meet Baker Mayfield their brother's a
big celebrity and they got two Baker's
friends that are regular dudes that are
talking to your sisters and being real I
love this night keep going tell me
there's an invite for me and Leanne
we'll be the last ones Leanne would get
an invite
and she can bring a plus one that's me
this is a [ __ ] Baker Mayfield I'm
getting [ __ ] up with your sisters his
buddies brought weed I can't [ __ ]
wait hey bring the pastor from the
Hillsong group all right Carl's in Carl
did it with Bieber yeah we got Bieber
Carl your sisters Baker his boys his
chick my chick you we need a girl for
you oh that is the biggest question of
all who's it gonna be I would say
celebrity invite a Groove scene from
afar who you respect maybe she's an
actress maybe she's a singer-songwriter
and it's it's a retail hey this is the
text hey me and my buddy Bert hmm
are taking my sisters his wife My Buddy
Baker Mayfield his buddies to go see
Morgan Whalen
I would love for you to come as my plus
one
um
who is she she's gonna hear this who is
she though she's going to hear this I
don't know who she is okay let's see
let's see is it let's okay
I'll tell you the ones the ones that are
undeniable to me Charlize Theron
okay uh Jennifer Aniston
um okay
she been with too many guys for me okay
okay okay unnoted
um
uh who's uh oh how about the girl but
I'm about to go from uh Ozarks
oh yeah she'll be cool
you got the [ __ ]
and that's how our night ends and that's
our night ends if you want to stop me
you're gonna have to [ __ ] kill me
that's fire dude yeah that's a fun
button that is and she is a great
actress yeah she is how old is she let's
make sure she's clearable how old is she
we've had issues in our
Universe okay Ruth langmore Ruth
langmore yeah langmore is that a real
name oh that sounds like a dateable name
as well
yeah I like Ruth langmore I think would
be nice he would be fun it would be by
the way look we could if she could we
could get her drunk and like say the
line again say the line again and we're
in a [ __ ] Sprinter van Baker's got
his shirt off and he's like let's
[ __ ] go she's like yeah
you're gonna have to [ __ ] kill me
your sister's gonna hand on the wall
this thing's moving really fast lehan's
drunk she's playing with my dick in the
back that's what I'm talking about let's
burp that worm Morgan come to L.A yeah
Morgan let's go we got the livest group
ever coming back we're going backstage
and you know him back there dude
somebody can blow him I'll do it
oh damn brother ice cold dicks yeah bro
no warm dicks bro that someone clipped
this out and he's going home you gotta
watch the whole podcast man yeah man I
think you're you're missing something
man and what's great is we hang we wake
up hungover as [ __ ] oh Carl Lintz comes
in he's like hey guys how's everyone
feeling we're like oh a little rough and
he's like hey why don't we all bring it
in yeah
let's hold hands yeah and we're like
he's like dear Lord
we had a great night last night amen
Lord I want you to look at everyone
right now and fill them with your love
fill them with your respect your honor
and I want you to take them from the
place they are and lift them up to where
they should be for the rest of the day
Lord I am Carl I got a direct
communication line with you do what you
did for Bieber for them
and let them have a great day who wants
waffles
yeah we all go get [ __ ] waffles God
waffles dude God waffles I love that
man we had quite a time uh
uh can I just say this might be the best
podcast I've ever been on this is the
funnest time I've had in a long [ __ ]
time oh thanks man you're the best are
you the best I'm I'm so
I love watching you you're so funny
you're so [ __ ] talented man and
you're not you're just an inspiration
for so many of us out there like just to
to try to step up our level podcasting
and to step up or try to step up our
level stand up you're so [ __ ]
talented buddy I'm so glad to have you
as friend oh thank you dude well you're
an Inspire you're you're an inspiring
guy you bring good energy man and um
yeah you just don't you just keep going
bro and that's a big part of life man it
really is you know sometimes if you
don't let the [ __ ] catch up with you
because some of us stop there and wait
[ __ ] sit for it yeah you know and
that's and it'll meet you there it's a
good that's a good analogy you need to
treat the what you need to treat the bad
[ __ ] the way horses treat [ __ ] just
comes out their ass and they keep
walking yeah they keep proofing like
that's not my problem I don't know who
you're talking about someone else is
getting that for me yeah yeah yeah
ladies and gentlemen bird Chrysler you
can check out the uh birdie boy relapse
tour yup um we're hitting Alaska uh
December 15th uh going all through Texas
all through Lafayette you're near your
hometown oh there you go yeah I'm in
Vancouver Victoria this weekend if your
when's this come out
um that comes out next week next week
next week next week this week uh Red
Rocks sold out Cajun dome in Lafayette
Corpus Christi Lubbock wow yeah so uh
got a bunch of dates and like I said
Alaska and secret time I'll be in uh
Europe dude I'm so proud of you and
amazed and uh I love the idea of betting
on yourself betting up that moment where
you're like you know what I'm gonna do
Red Rock and now you're doing it again
doing it again sold out quicker I'll do
it again next year too I love it
nerevrock's one of the coolest places
I've ever performed in my life look
Sebastian has Madison Square Garden that
makes sense that that's his Mecca yeah
you know
um uh I for me Red Rocks is like
it's like we're staying the next night
to watch Wilco wilco's one of my
favorite bands in the world I can't wait
to go to Wilco with Shane Gillis Mark
Normand my wife I got I did the same
thing I did for damn dude I got a whole
I got a whole set of cabins like 12
cabins for everyone on a River in
Evergreen Colorado I got everyone cabins
I got us all coming in Sprinter vans
there Sprinter vans to our show IVs in
the morning Sprinter vans back big party
next morning IV's Sprinter Vander Wilco
everyone merches it out we got to meet
Jeff Tweedy hopefully hopefully I can
talk to Jeff Tweety the same way I talk
to you about pre-sale
because I think Jeff tweedy's leaving
some money on the floor anyway but uh
but yeah I can't wait man it's the
[ __ ] best and I'm bringing my trainer
we're gonna work out hard every morning
ah I can't [ __ ] wait and then we fly
out we fly out from uh Red Rocks private
to Lafayette to do the Cajun Dome um
[ __ ] pump dude this is what oh man
I'm just I love I love it you're living
you're dreaming you're lit you're not
only you're living here but you're
choosing to live here you're like I'm
gonna not only be here alive in my dream
but I'm going to live a dream yeah and
that's uh that's another way of thinking
man thank you very much yeah thank you
buddy
[Music]
[Music]
but it's gonna take